GOOD AFTERNOON TARGET MORNING
LIKE THEY COULD --
CONVENE THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE --
SERGEANT PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
I'M NOTICING A QUORUM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
COME LIVE IT UP [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS HERE [inaudible]
PACSUN QUICKSILVER [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
NOTICING THE ABSENCE OF SENATE
BILL WE OWN A WILL PROCEED WITH
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS.
AND WOULD MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. B. EIGHT TO TO A
MISTER WEINER.
CHAIR I KNOW THAT YOU'VE MADE
DOT SOME AMENDMENTS --
TO THIS BILL IN THE ANALYSIS I'D
LIKE -- TO
MOVE THE AMENDMENTS PER THE
ANALYSIS RECOMMENDATION.
IF I THEIR SUPPORT FOR SECOND
[inaudible]
WELL FIRST.
THE FEC AND THEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
WE HAVE A HEARING ON THIS BILL.
I I DON'T ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMONG THE SANTIAGO.
AYE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE --
MISSED YOUR AYE.
NOT NECESSARILY HOW I DON'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH MAYBE THE OUTCOME
OF WHAT THE MOTION REPRESENTS
[inaudible]
BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE --
MAY BE MORE APPROPRIATE TO ALLOW
THE PRESENTATION BY THE AUTHOR
TO AT LEAST.
PRESENT --
THE THE FUNDAMENTALS OF HIS BILL
SO THAT THERE COULD BE --
NO REFLECTION AND IN PART OF
ULTIMATE DELIBERATION.
AND AYE I MAY END UP IN PROBABLY
WOULD SUPPORT.
OF INTENT OF WHERE YOU'RE GOING
BUT THERE MAY BE SOME
APPROPRIATE QUESTIONS IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE CONVERSATION.
NOT SURE IF ANY TO BE PART OF
MOTION BUT I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
WHAT -- OUR
COLLEAGUE HAS STATED.
WE'RE HERE FOR HEARING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE
THEIR ARE HAVING A HEARING WHICH
WERE ENTITLED TO ON THIS BILL.
PRETTY ASSEMBLY RULES WHICH
REQUIRE THAT WE RECEIVE A
HEARING.
ONLY TO BE A MOTION BEFORE US A
LIKE A VOTE ON IT NOW.
JUST ON THE AMENDMENTS.
BUT WITHOUT WITHOUT HEARING
MISTER CHAIRMAN ONE SECOND.
WE WOULD STILL HAVE A HEARING
WILL BE BY YOUR VOTING BEFORE.
YOU WENT HOME TO YOUR FAMILIES
AND YOUR VOTING BEFORE THE
HEARING EVEN HAPPENS.
HOUSE OUT APPROPRIATE
[inaudible]
NO
.
WELL MOTION BEFORE THE BODY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MEANT TO
CARRY.
MOTION ON THE AMENDMENTS.
SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE BONTA
[inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE HOLDEN
.
HARDER NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF NOT VOTING.
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
I THINK I JUST.
JOINT MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
OF MY TWO PREDECESSORS BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE A VOTE IN FRONT OF US
I AM GONNA VOTE SO --
BUT I DO --
JUST FOR THE RECORD JOIN IN THE
COMMENTS OF OF MY COLLEAGUES BUT
I VOTE I MAIENSCHEIN AYE.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUICKSILVER
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ SIGH [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
WE ARE VOTING ON WE'RE GOING TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT --
FOUND IN THE ANALYSIS A TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
CERVANTES AYE.
IT WAS HERE THE MOTION PASSES.
MISTER WEINER ME MAY PROCEED ON
S. B. [inaudible]
EIGHT TWO TWO I AM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO
START OUT BY SAYING ARE.
THAT WAY BY THE COMMITTEES AS
DID WAS OUTRAGEOUS ARE THIS
THESE AMENDMENTS WERE ISSUE TO
THE PUBLIC AT TEN PM.
LAST NIGHT.
AT TEN PM LAST NIGHT BUT EVEN OF
TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO REVIEW
THESE AMENDMENTS AS I WILL
DESCRIBE MY STATEMENT.
IV AMENDMENTS OF THE COMMISSION
IS ADOPTED IF VISSER RATE THE
BILL IT'S NO LONGER A REAL NET
NEUTRALITY BELL --
AND IT IS ASTOUNDING TO ME THAT
THE COMMITTEE WOULD AND THAT YOU
WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE TO TAKE
ABOUT BOW.
BEFORE HEARING MY PRESENTATION
BEFORE HEARING PUBLIC COMMENT
BEFORE HEARING SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. FOR AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE ISSUED.
ARE A PRODUCT LESS THAN TWELVE
HOURS AGO ON SO I WILL STATE FOR
THE RECORD I THINK WHAT'S
HAPPENED.
IT WAS I THINK IT WAS A
VIOLATION OF ASSEMBLY RULES BUT
EVEN IF IT WASN'T.
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR.
SO COLLEAGUES THAT MYSTERY NAM
ALSO DISAPPOINT THAT WE COULD
NOT -- COME
TO A CONCLUSION --
AND THAT I THINK THIS IS JUST A
STARTING POINT TO A CONVERSATION.
I DON'T SEE THIS ISN'T INTO
CONVERSATION I DON'T --
AND IT'S YOU KNOW I'VE DISCUSSED
BACK AND FORTH IN WITHOUT A
VIGOROUS DEBATE AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT WE BOTH BELIEVE A NET
NEUTRALITY BILL* OUT WE BOTH
BELIEVE.
WERE AIMING AT THE SAME
DIRECTION --
IN THE INTEREST IN THIS
COMMITTEE ARE WE CAN CONTINUE
OUR DEBATE OUTSIDE OF THE OF THE
SITE COMMITTEE ROOM.
I DO ONE ESTABLISH SOME RULES UP
FOR PRESENTATION.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA PROCEED AS YOU
DO THIRTY MINUTES ON EACH SIDE --
AND TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS.
THEREAFTER WILL PROCEED WITH THE
FOREIGN AGAINST AND FOLKS WILL
ONLY BE ABLE TO STATE THEIR NAME.
AND THEIR POSITION.
I'M SORRY CAN YOU REPEAT THEM
ETCETERA THIRTY MINUTES TOTAL ON
EACH SIDE SO WILL ALLOW THIRTY
MINUTES FOR THE FOR THIRTY
MINUTES FOR THE AGAINST.
AND WILL DO TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS --
HERE SO EACH SIDE COULD BREAK
THEM UP AUTHOR AND A TWO MINUTE
SEGMENTS.
AFTER THAT WHEN WE GO THROUGH
THE SUPPORTERS IN IN THE
OPPOSITION.
I'D PEOPLE ALWAYS TO BE ABLE TO
STATE THEIR NAME AND THE
POSITION.
AFTER THIRTY MINUTES IS A
COMBINATION OF MY PRESENTATION
AND OUR WITNESS AND YOU
WITNESSES YES.
AND I WOULD RECOMMEND THAT'S TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS.
BUT IT'S THIRTY MINUTES TOTAL.
THAT'S JUST A COMEDY AS MANY
WINS AS POSSIBLE THIRTY MINUTES
OF OKAY.
NOW COLLEAGUES I AM ASSUMING --
LITTLE ALLERGY ISSUE.
I'M COLLEAGUES I'D NINE DAYS AGO
NET NEUTRALITY ENDED AND THE
UNITED STATES.
IT ENDED BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP'S
FCC.
I ERASED ESSENTIALLY ALL FEDERAL
NET NEUTRALITY REGULATIONS.
ON TOP OF THAT LAST WEEK THAT
SAW THE ASTOUNDING APPROVAL OF
E. TNT'S ACQUISITION.
OF TIME WARNER. FOR EIGHTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
A MASSIVE CONSOLIDATION OF
INTERNET ACCESS --
WITH MEDIA CONTENT.
COMCAST HAS NOW INDICATED THAT
IT INTENDS. TO ACQUIRE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY FOX FOR SIXTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF IS THE SAME
COMPANIES WHO ARE TELLING YOU
THAT IF THEY CAN'T CHARGE
INTERCONNECTION THIEVES TO ALLOW
ACCESS -- IF
THEY CAN'T BLOCKING THROTTLE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE POOR
AND NOT BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
THEIR NETWORK EIGHTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR ACQUISITION SIXTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR ACQUISITION.
THIS MEANS THAT A TNT COMCAST
AND OTHER INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
CANAL DECIDE THAT YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO USE CERTAIN APPS OR
VISIT CERTAIN WEBSITES ON YOUR
PHONE THAT'S THE STATE OF THE
WORLD TODAY THEY CAN BLOCK.
THROTTLE MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
THE SIDE YOU CAN ONLY GO TO
THESE WEBSITES YOU CAN'T GO
ANYWHERE ELSE OUT WHERE WE ARE
TODAY.
I AND THEY CAN MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS BASED PURELY ON THEIR
BOTTOM LINE WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE
THEM MORE MONEY.
BASED ON WHO IS PAYING THEM MORE
BIG WEBSITE BIG SERVICE COMPEL
LOT OF MONEY.
ANYONE WHO HAPPENS TO BE A START
UP FOR AN INDIVIDUAL OR AN
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION WHETHER
YOU ARE THE TEA PARTY OR WHETHER
YOU ARE THE COURAGE CAMPAIGN.
ARE YOU CAN BE BLOCKED OR
THROTTLED IF THE ISP DOESN'T
LIKE YOU WERE NOT PAYING THEM
ENOUGH --
YOUR INTERNET MORE AND MORE WILL
START TO LOOK LIKE CABLE TV.
WHERE YOU PAY A BIG MONTHLY FEE?
AYE AYE AND THEY TELL YOU HERE
ARE THE TOP YOU GO.
TO AND YOU DON'T EVEN SEE THE
ONES THAT THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO
GO TO PRISON NOT PAYING THEM
ENOUGH MONEY.
AND CONTRARY TO THE CLAIMS FROM
SOME OF THE BILL'S OPPONENTS
THESE NET NEUTRALITY VIOLATIONS
ABSOLUTELY HAPPEN.
WE SAW IT WHEN A TNT BLOCKED
SKYPE AND FACETIME YOUR MEMBER
THAT.
WENT EIGHTEEN TO SPRINT AND
VERIZON ALL BLOCKED GOOGLE
WALLET BECAUSE IT WAS A
COMPETITOR.
WHEN A CANADIAN ISP BLOCK THE
ORGANIZING WEBSITE THAT ITS
WORKERS WERE USING THE FORM A
LABOR UNION?
CALIFORNIA COLLEAGUES HAS A
GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY.
OUGHT TO SEND A POWERFUL MESSAGE
YET AGAIN THAT WE ARE A
PROGRESSIVE LEADER NATIONALLY.
THAT STRONG PUBLIC POLICY STARTS
HEARING CALIFORNIA.
OR WE CAN PASS A WE'RE COMPELLED
TO PASS A STRONG THAT NEUTRALITY
BILL WE CAN PASS --
A WEEK NET NEUTRALITY BILL SUCH
AS THE ONE THAT IS NOW AMENDED
BEFORE YOU.
SPEND SOME A POWERFUL NEGATIVE
MESSAGE.
AFTERALL HOW CAN WE EXPECT
CONGRESS TO PASS REBUTS NET
NEUTRALITY PROTECTIONS.
IF CALIFORNIA CAN'T EVEN GET IT
TOGETHER TO DO SO.
WE WOULD ALL PREFER ONE STRONG
UNIFORM NET NEUTRALITY STANDARDS
AT A NATIONAL LEVEL --
BUT THE REALITY WE FACE IS THERE
ARE NO FEDERAL PROTECTIONS IT IS
NOW UP TO THE STATES TO ACT.
THE CORE PHILOSOPHY UNDERLYING
THE NEUTRALITY IS THAT INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS DON'T GET TO
PICK WINNERS AND LOSERS ON THE
INTERNET.
THEY DON'T GET TO THE SIDE WHERE
WE CAN GO OR WHERE WE CAN'T GO.
THEY DON'T GET TO DECIDE WHICH
MEDIA HE'D OR FAIL.
WITHOUT CLEAR PROTECTIONS THE
INTERNET IS A DRAMATIC RISK OF
LOSING ITS STATUS AS A PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE WERE ALL OF US CAN
GO WHERE WE WANT TO GO.
AND USE WHATEVER SERVICES WE
WANT TO USE --
IT'LL BE CHANGED TO A PLACE
WHERE WE ARE FORCED OR
MANIPULATED TO GO ONLY WHERE THE
BIG TELECOM AND CABLE COMPANIES
WANT US TO GO.
BASED ON WHERE THEY MAKE MORE
MONEY.
I AM PROUD TO PARTNER WITH
SENATOR KEVIN DE LEóN IN THIS
EFFORT.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO IN
COMBINATION WITH SENATOR DALY
OWNS SP FOUR SIXTY WILL SET THE
GOLD STANDARD NATIONALLY FOR NET
NEUTRALITY.
LAST THURSDAY SENATOR DE LEóN
AND I REACH AGREEMENT ON NOT
HAVING TO COMPETING BILLS BUT
MAKING THEM JOINED AND
COMPLIMENTARY --
WE SUBMITTED AMENDMENTS --
TO THE COMMITTEE --
TO DO THAT AND THE COMMITTEE
DECLINES --
TO CROSS THOSE AMENDMENTS.
I S. B. TWENTY TWO IS AYE
STANDARDS BROADLY PROTECT NET
NEUTRALITY THEY PROHIBIT ISPS
FROM BLOCKING OR THROTTLING
WEBSITES.
FROM CREATING FAST LANES AND
SLOW LANES OF FROM CHARGING TO
SPEED UP TRAFFIC.
S. B. A TWENTY TWO DOZEN JUSTIN
SHORE NET NEUTRALITY ON THE I.
S. P.'S OWN NETWORK.
IT ALSO ENSURES THAT AYE IT'S
PLEASE DON'T LEVERAGE WHERE
OTHER NETWORKS FEED INTO THOSE
NETWORKS WHAT'S CALLED INNER
CONNECTION. TO AVOID NET
NEUTRALITY.
IF YOU ARE PROTECTING THAT
NEUTRALITY ONLY ON THE ISPS
NETWORK BUT NOT AT THE POINT OF
INTERCONNECTION WHICH IS WHAT
THESE AMENDMENTS DO.
THERE'S NO NET NEUTRALITY
BECAUSE ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS
BLOCK OR THROTTLE OR SLOW YOU
DOWN AT THE POINT OF
INTERCONNECTION AND YOU HAVE NO
NINETY TRIAL IT.
I S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO ALSO
BANS CORPORATE SELF DEALING --
SOMETIMES CALLED ZERO RATING
THAT IS HIGHLY ANTI COMPETITIVE
AND ANTI CONSUMER AND AS A WAY
FOR THE EYES PEAS TO FORCE POOR
PEOPLE TO USE ONLY A SMALL
NUMBER OF WEBSITES --
THESE TYPES ZERO RATING --
PLANS ARE --
THEY THEY ARE HIGHLY HIGHLY.
SO WHO IS SUPPORTING AND
OPPOSING.
OUR VERSION OF A TWENTY TWO NOT
THE MUTILATED VERSION NOW
PENDING BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT WHO'S SUPPORTING AND
OPPOSING SB TWENTY TWO SP TWENTY
TWO IS SUPPORTED BY THE PEOPLE
WHO WROTE THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
OBAMA NET NEUTRALITY ORDER.
INCLUDING OBAMA'S FCC CHAIRMAN
TOM WHEELER WHO SUPPORTS SB
TWENTY TWO OTHER COMMISSIONERS.
AS WELL WHO'S OPPOSING IT.
THE SAME CORPORATIONS THAT GOD
DONALD TRUMP'S FCC TO REPEAL NET
NEUTRALITY A TNT COMCAST VERIZON
ETCETERA THAT IS THE FIELD HERE.
AYE IT DOES AS YOU PROBABLY
ALREADY KNOW SP TWENTY TWO IS
ALSO SUPPORTED BY HOUSE
DEMOCRATIC LEADER NANCY PELOSI
WHO SENT THE CHAIRMAN A LETTER A
FEW DAYS AGO.
ASKING HIM NOT TO DO WITH THIS
COMMITTEE JUST DEAD TO GOT THE
BILL.
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOBBY ARE BUT
SARA SUPPORTS IT A BROAD LABOR
COALITION LED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION.
A HUGE LIST OF OUR ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE ACLU
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY NEXT GEN COLOR OF CHANGE
THE LA DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
FEDERATION AND ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION ALL SUPPORT
THE VERSION.
OF THE BILL BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE JUST MUTILATED.
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
[inaudible]
OVERWHELMINGLY PORTENTS REALITY --
AND JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT.
IN THE U. S. SENATE EVEN THE
ONES WHO ARE IN JEOPARDY OF NOT
BEING REELECTED PLUS THREE
REPUBLICANS VOTED TO RESTORE THE
STRONG THAT NEUTRALITY
PROTECTIONS FROM THE OBAMA ORDER
WHICH ARE INCLUDED.
IN THE ARBORS INVESTED TWENTY
TWO BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AMANDA.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS --
IF HISTORY THE BILL.
AND ELIMINATE CORNET ACTUALITY
PROTECTIONS.
ARE THE AMENDMENTS I TURNED THIS
BILL INTO A BILL THAT DOES NOT
ACTUALLY PROTECT NET NEUTRALITY.
IT IS NOW WITH THE AMENDMENTS A
FAKE NET NEUTRALITY BILL --
THE AMENDMENTS CHERRY PICK.
CHERRY PICK FROM THE OBAMA
TWENTY FIFTEEN NET NEUTRALITY
ORDER -- AND
AND THIS IS A ORDER WAS HUNDREDS
OF PAGES LONG.
AND BASICALLY TAKE TWO PAGES AND
SAY THIS IS ALL WE'RE DOING.
AND IGNORE EVERYTHING ELSE.
THE OBAMA ORDER.
DETECTIVE THAT NEUTRALITY AT THE
POINT OF INNER. FOR EXAMPLE.
PROHIBITED FEEDS TO ACCESS AN
ICE PLEASE CUSTOMERS.
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS STRIP
ALL OF THAT OUT THESE AMENDMENTS.
MAKE THIS BILL FALL FAR SHORT.
OF THE OBAMA TWENTY FIFTEEN NET
NEUTRALITY ORDER DESPITE WHAT A
TNT AND OTHERS ARE SAYING AND
INTENSELY LOBBYING THIS
COMMITTEE THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THIS BILL IS NOW FAR SHORT OF
WHERE THE OBAMA ORDER WAS.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I DO
NOT STOP.
OR PREVENT ISPS FROM BLOCKING
THROTTLING OR SLOWING DOWN
WEBSITES BEGINS AS DO THAT NOW
AT THE POINT OF INTERCONNECTION --
AND THIS DOES NOT --
AND THIS HAS THE SAME AND READ
WE HAD NO BILL AT ALL.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ALLOW
THE ICE PIECE TO CREATE FAST
LANES TO ENHANCE OR SPEED UP
FAVORED WEBSITES TO PAY MORE.
WHILE RELEGATING EVERYONE ELSE.
TO A SLOWER TRAFFIC LANES.
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR PASSING
LANES FOR FOR COMPANIES THAT
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY FOR IT.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL
ALLOW --
EIGHTEEN T. AND OTHER ISPS TO
THROTTLE AN ENTIRE CLASS OF
APPLICATIONS OF FOR EXAMPLE E.
TNT COULD DECIDE THAT IT IS
GOING TO THROTTLE.
ALL TELEPHONY APPLICATIONS LIKE
SKYPE REMINDED BECAUSE THOSE ARE
COMPETING AGAINST EIGHTEEN TEETH
TELEPHONY SERVICES.
THEN AMENDMENTS DO NOT PROHIBIT
THAT.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL
THEY'LL.
THE EIGHTEEN T. TO ENGAGE IN
CORPORATE SELF DEALING.
BY FAVORING ITS MASSIVE TIME
WARNER MEDIA SITES OVER
COMPETITORS SITES BY SAYING HEY
VIEWS MY MEDIA SITES IT DOESN'T
COUNT AGAINST YOUR DATA IF YOU
USE MY COMPETITORS YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO PAY DATA.
I V. COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
ELIMINATE THE BILLS PROHIBITION
ON QUOTES ENGAGING IN DECEPTIVE
OR MISLEADING MARKETING
PRACTICES THAT MISREPRESENT THE
TREATMENT OF INTERNET TRAFFIC.
DOW WAS DELETED IN THE
AMENDMENTS THESE US ADOPTED.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ALLOW
ISPS TO CHARGE WEBSITE
GATEKEEPER FEES FOR ACCESS THE
ISP CUSTOMERS AND IF THEY DON'T
PAY.
THOSE WEBSITE TO BECOME
INVISIBLE TO CONSUMERS.
AGAIN THE WHOLE POINT IN THAT
NEUTRALITY IS THAT WE GET TO THE
SIDE WHERE WE GO.
BUT THE INNER ICE CUBES ARE NOT
THE ONES TO PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS.
YEAH DOT IS EXACTLY WHAT BE
AMENDED VERSION OF THE BILL.
THAT THIS COMMITTEE JUST VOTED
TO ADOPT BEFORE EVEN HEARING THE
BILL WILL DO.
I COLLEAGUES WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO STAND UP
FOR AN OPEN INTERNET.
AND FOR THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO RELY ON IT FOR
AN INCREASING ARRAY OF NEEDS.
FOR THE BUSINESSES WHETHER
NONPROFITS LARGE COMPANIES START
UPS BRICK AND MORTAR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
I CANNOT FUNCTION WITHOUT FAIR
INTERNET ACCESS FOR THE OUT
TICKETS TO HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE.
AND PLAY SUCH AN ESSENTIAL ROLE
IN OUR DEMOCRACY. FOR THE LABOR
UNIONS WHO WORK TO MAKE LIFE
BETTER FOR WORKING PEOPLE. FOR
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO CARE
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS WHO INCREASINGLY RELY
ON THE INTERNET TO DELIVER CARE.
AND SO FORTH OUGHT AND YET FOR
ALL THOSE PEOPLE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU JUST ADOPTED BEFORE
EVEN HEARING THE BILL --
IF DISARRAY THOSE PROTECTIONS
WILL NOT ACTUALLY.
APPLY NEUTRALITY YOU CAN LABEL
THAT CHARLIE BILL IT'S NOT WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS --
SO COLLEAGUES I HOPE YOU WILL
RESEND THOSE AMENDMENTS AND PASS
AN ACTUAL NET NEUTRALITY BILL
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE I'D TO
REITERATE I DO NOT ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS --
AND THE BILL IS.
I I DON'T SUPPORT THAT OF THE
AMENDED VERSION OF THE BILL.
WITH ME TODAY ARE TO WIN THIS IS
A BARBER BANSHEE BECK WHO IS A
LAW PROFESSOR AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY --
WITH A PEACHY INVOLVED A
NEUTRALITY FOR MANY YEARS AND
PAUL GOODMAN FROM THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE.
CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO TESTIFY TODAY.
MY NAME IS BARBARA FRENCHIE VIC
I'M A PROFESSOR OF LAW AT
STANFORD LAW SCHOOL AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
INTERNET AND SOCIETY THERE.
I'VE A PHD IN COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND A LAW DEGREE.
I'M HERE AS AN INDEPENDENT
ACADEMIC WHO HAS WORKED ON NET
NEUTRALITY FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS.
THE F. C. C.'S TWENTY TEN AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN OPEN INTERNET
RULES RELY HEAVILY ON MY WORK.
AS DID THE INDIAN AND CANADIAN
RULES ON ZERO RATING AND THE E.
USENET NEUTRALITY GUIDELINES.
TODAY YOU ARE FACING A CHOP AT
STARK CHOICE YOU CAN PAUSE S. B.
A TWENTY TWO BRING MAGNITUDE
CELTIC TO CALIFORNIA AND RESTORE
THE IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS THE
FCC VOTED TO REPEAL IN DECEMBER
[inaudible]
INSTEAD.
YOU JUST VOTED TO ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS THAT EFFECTIVELY GOT
THE BILL AND LEAVE CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS.
WHEN I I THE TIME WITH THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER?
LAST WEEK NET NEUTRALITY AND IT
EIGHTEEN TEAM WHICH WAS TIME
WORN OUT WITHOUT ANY PROTECTIONS
ADOPTED FOR THE DEAL.
AND CON BECAUSE OFFER TO BUY A
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY FOX.
THAT MEANS THAT THE MEGA
CORPORATIONS LIKE AGENCY OR
COMCAST THAT OWN THE CONTENT NOW
ALSO OWN THE PIPES THAT DELIVER
THAT CONTENT.
AND WITHOUT NET NEUTRALITY
PROTECTIONS.
THE SIZE PIECE HAVE THE MEANS
MOTIVE AND OPPORTUNITY.
TOLD THE INTERNET IN THEIR FAVOR.
AT THE EXPENSE OF EVERYONE ELSE
FROM STARTUPS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES TO COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
S. B. A TWENTY TWO IS CAREFULLY
DRAFTED TO PREVENT OUT BY
INCORPORATING BOTH.
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN RULES AND THE
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS FROM THE
TEXT OF THE ORDER.
THAT'S WHY IT'S WIDELY VIEWED AS
A NET NEUTRALITY MODEL BILL.
THAT WOULD SET THE STANDARD FOR
OTHER STATES AND ULTIMATELY THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND THAT'S WHY FCC CHAIRMAN TOM
WHEELER THE GUY WHO LITERALLY
WROTE THE ORDER.
PORTS SP A TWENTY TWO IT'S THE
ONLY STATE LEVEL BILL HE
SUPPORTS THAT SHOULD TELL YOU
GUYS SOMETHING [inaudible]
BY CONTRAST THE CHAIRS
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU JUST ACCEPT
IT.
OUR A FRONTAL ASSAULT ON NET
NEUTRALITY MAKE NO MISTAKE THE
SUN NOT SOME MODIFICATIONS
AROUND THE EDGES.
ANY BILL THAT AFTER THESE
AMENDMENTS ICE PIECE ON NOW FREE
TO CHARGE WEBSITES FOR ACCESS TO
THE CUSTOMERS AND WE TALK.
MISTER WINNER. TWENTY VICE IT
IT'S TWO MINUTES YOU MAY CHOOSE
TO CONTINUE BUT I I SAID I WOULD
ADVISE.
YES YOU MAY WISH TO CONTINUE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT I WANTED BY SOME AFTER THE
EAST AFTER THESE AMENDMENTS ICE
CUBES ARE NOW FREE TO BLOCK
EVERY WHAT TO CHARGE EVERY
WEBSITE A FEW FOR ACCESS TO
THEIR CUSTOMERS.
AND BLOCK EVERY WEBSITE THAT
DOESN'T PAY THEM A FEW.
THAT MEANS IF YOUR LOCAL SCHOOL
HASN'T PAID YOUR I SP YOU WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO GET TO YOUR
SCHOOL'S WEBSITE.
AFTER THESE AMENDMENTS ICE PIECE
CAN NOW BLOCK SLOW DOWN WATCH
HOT FOOT TRAFFIC AT THE POINT
WHERE DATA AND TEST THE NETWORK
BECAUSE YOU GOT IT.
THE PROTECTIONS AGAINST
CIRCUMVENTING THE RULES AT THE
POINT WHERE DATA AND HAS THE
NETWORK.
AFTER THE AMENDMENTS ICED HE'S
ON ALL FREE TO SLOW DOWN HALL
CLASSES OF TRAFFIC [inaudible]
SPEED UP.
INDIVIDUAL APPLICATIONS ALL
WHOLE CLASSES OF APPLICATION.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT YOU
REALLY WANT TO DO ICON IMAGINE
THAT THAT'S THE INTENT OF YOUR
AMENDMENTS.
AND AFTER THE AMEND VANCE AT AND
HE CAN COUNT EVERY WEEK VIDEO ON
THE INTERNET AGAINST USE US
ARTIFICIALLY LOW.
DATA CAPS WHILE EXEMPTING THE
CONTENT IT OWNS ITSELF.
A BILL THAT ALLOWS BIASED PIECE
TO DO ALL THESE THINGS IS NOT
NET NEUTRALITY.
SO TODAY THE INTERNET AS A SPACE
WHERE EVERY CALIFORNIAN NO
MATTER THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN
OF THE SIZE OF THE WALLETS.
HAS AN EQUAL CHANCE OF REACHING
PEOPLE ONLINE.
IT'S IS SPACE WHERE WE THE
PEOPLE NOT AYE IS PEACE
DETERMINE WHAT SUCCEEDS IN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
OUR CULTURE AND OUR ECONOMY.
BY CONFERENCING RESTORING THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN PROTECTIONS SBA
TWENTY TWO WOULD KEEP IT THAT
WAY.
AS SENATOR MARKEY SAID YESTERDAY
ALL EYES ON CALIFORNIA.
I URGE YOU TO SEIZE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT THIS
GREAT STATE AND LEAD THE NATION.
AND RECONSIDER YOUR DECISION AND
PAUSE SP AB TWENTY TWO WITHOUT
THAT YES AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
[inaudible]
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS PAUL GIVEN I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE GREEN LINING INSTITUTE
AND THE CENTER FOR MEDIA JUSTICE.
BUT ASK THE COMMITTEE.
TO EXCEPT AS BE EIGHT TWENTY TWO
WITHOUT THE AMENDMENTS THAT JUST
SIGNIFICANT WE CAN THE BELL.
AND ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS TO
JOIN SB A TWENTY TWO WITH SP.
A FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
UNFAMILIAR WITH GREEN LINING
GREEN LINE IS A PUBLIC POLICY
RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
ENSURE THE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
INCOME IN CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS
THE SAME ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AS
THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS.
NET NEUTRALITY IS A KEY PART OF
OUR WORK. FOR THE PAST SEVEN
YEARS I'VE REPRESENTED GREEN
LIGHTING ON TELECOMMUNICATION
ANTITRUST ISSUES AND PRIOR TO
JOINING GREEN LIGHTING I WORKED
ON THAT EACH CHILD ISSUES FOR
THE BROADBAND INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA.
I CURRENTLY SERVE ON THE ASK
FEDERAL COMMUNICATION
COMMISSIONS CONSUMER ADVISORY
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OF FIRST.
I JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT A AND
THE FCC'S LATEST.
RULING ON NET NEUTRALITY IT WAS
VERY DISAPPOINTING TO SEE THAT
THAT COMMISSION MADE THE
DECISION TO LOCK THE PUBLIC.
OUT OF THE DISCUSSION BY DECIDED
TO IGNORE PUBLIC COMMENTS AND I
AM PROFOUNDLY DISAPPOINTED TO
SEE THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
DECIDED DO THE SAME.
BY VOTING ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WITHOUT ANY IMPLIED
[inaudible]
BOB.
BUT I'M HERE SPECIFICALLY TODAY
TO TALK ADDRESS INDUSTRY CLAIMS
A STRONG NET NEUTRALITY
PROTECTIONS SOMEHOW HARM
COMMITTEES OF COLOR IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES I'M HERE SAY
THOSE CLAIMS ARE NEITHER GENUINE
MARK TRUE.
IT'S DEEPLY FRUSTRATING TO SEE
ISPS STUMBLING ALL OVER
THEMSELVES TO PRAY TRADE
THEMSELVES IS DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT A COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AS THIS COMMITTEE IS NO DOUBT
AWARE AYE LAST WEEK CAL
INNOVATES RELEASED A STUNNINGLY
DISINGENUOUS THREE PAGE DOCUMENT.
I'M MAKING THE UNDERPLAYED
SUPPORT A CLAIM THAT STRONG NET
NEUTRALITY PROTECTIONS THAT HARM
COMMITTEES CALLER AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES BY INCREASING THE
COST OF MOBILE DATA SERVICES BY
AS MUCH AS THIRTY DOLLARS A
MONTH.
I'VE WORKED FOR REMAINING OVER
AS A SET FOR SEVEN YEARS ABOUT
THAT THE CPUC AND THE FCC
WORKING ON MATTERS --
AS VARIED AS MERGER OF YOU LOW
INCOME PROGRAMS PRIVACY ISSUES
AND NET NEUTRALITY.
OVER THOSE SEVEN YEARS I HAVE
CONSISTENTLY ASKED AYE AYES
PIECE DIVIDE ME DATA ABOUT HOW
THEIR BUSINESS DECISIONS HOW
THEIR BUSINESS MODELS AFFECT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND IF
THERE'S ANY DISPARATE TREATMENT
I'VE RECEIVED THREE RESPONSES.
ONE WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATA. TWO
WE DON'T HAVE ANY WAY TO COLLECT
THAT DATA ANALYZE THAT DATA AND
THREE AYE IF WE DID COLLECT THAT
DATA ANALYZE THAT DATA THAT
LEAVE US OPEN TO A LAWSUIT FOR
DISCRIMINATION SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY INFORMATION ABOUT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
[inaudible]
YET TODAY.
THESE BROADBAND PROVIDERS HAVE
RACKED THE COME UP OF ANALYSIS
AND NOW SAYS OH ZERO RATING.
OF THAT IS SOMEHOW GOING TO HARM
COMMUNITIES.
CONTRARY TO I SP CLAIMS THE
WEAKER WATER DOWN THAT METALLIC
PROTECTIONS ACTUALLY THREATEN TO
HARM COMMITTEES OF COLOR.
THAT STRONG ZERO RATING BANDS ON
DISCRIMINATORY ZERO RATING.
OF SPEAKERS AND TRADERS OF COLOR.
WHO CAN'T PAY FOR INTERNET FAST
LANES OR ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE
PICKED BY HIGHEST FEES TO BE?
ZERO RATED IT'S GOING BE HARDER
FOR THEM TO PRODUCE I OR OR
PRODUCE OR PROFIT FROM.
THEIR OWN CREATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY AS THEIR RATING
INCENTIVIZE ISP'S TO KEEP DATA
CAPS LOW IN ORDER TO MOTIVATE
WEBSITES TO PAY FOR ZERO RATING
AND THOSE ARTIFICIALLY LOW CAPS
WILL HIT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THE
HARDEST.
FINALLY WEEK NET NEUTRALITY
PROTECTIONS WITHOUT PRINT
PROHIBITIONS ON PAID
PRIORITIZATION ZERO RATING ROLE
WILL RESULT IN TWO KINDS OF
INTERNET SERVICES.
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND SERVICE FOR
THAT CONNECTS THOSE WHO CAN
AFFORD IT
AND SECOND CLASS SEPARATE AND
UNEQUAL BROADBAND SERVICE FOR
THOSE WHO CANNOT.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TELL THEIR OWN STORIES
WITHOUT I SP GATEKEEPERS
DECIDING WHETHER THOSE VOICES
ARE PROFITABLE ENOUGH TO BE
HEARD.
I HAVE ONE FINAL POINT.
AND THAT'S OF THE OPPONENTS OF
THIS BILL WILL DO ANYTHING TO
STOP THIS BODY FROM ENSURING
THAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
AN OPEN INTERNET.
I TO LIMIT NOT DEVELOP TEXANS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL ICE PIECE OF
THE SITE THEMSELVES.
WITH AN ADMINISTRATION AS
PARTICULARLY.
PERSISTENTLY ATTACKED AND THAT
MEANS OUR FRIENDS COMMUNITIES
AND LOVED ONES OF COLOR.
I ONE OPPONENT EIGHTEEN T. WENT
SO FAR AS TO PAY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR DIRECT
ACCESS TO DONALD TRUMP TO
FURTHER THEIR AGENDA.
AND UP AYE YOU NOTICED THE NEWS
YESTERDAY A T. MOBILE HAS JUST
HIRED COREY LEWANDOWSKI FORMER
TRUMP [inaudible]
CAMPAIGN.
A MANAGER TO HELP PUSH THROUGH
THIS IN THE SPRINT T. MOBILE
BELL AT CARLY LEWANDOWSKI ALSO
REPRESENTS BY THE WAY A COMPANY
THAT --
WHOSE BUSINESS IS PROVIDING.
WRITING INCARCERATION FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNDERGOING IMMIGRATION.
I MAKE NO MISTAKE A VOTE AGAINST
THIS BILL ABOUT FOR THIS WATER
DOWN BILL IS NOT JUST A VOTE TO
ENRICH AYE AS PEACE AT THE
EXPENSE OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES.
IS A BOAT TO SUPPORT AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT TARA
CHILDREN OF COLOR AWAY FROM
THEIR FAMILIES AND INCARCERATE
THEM IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS
CONCENTRATION CAMPS LIKE THE
ONES.
MY FAMILY DIED IN THE THIRTIES
AND FORTIES FOR CHAIRMAN CAN WE
STICK TO THE MERITS OF THE BILL
PLEASE.
I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ADOPT
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS --
REJECT THESE --
THE AMENDMENT SUGGESTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND VOTE YES
ON S. BEFORE SIXTY THANK YOU.
MISTER A FIFTEEN MINUTES LEFT ON
YOUR SIDE.
WERE THOSE ARE MY WITNESSES SO.
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AGAIN STATING YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY
.
MARK TONY THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK.
WE SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
TWO AS WRITTEN AND OPPOSE THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED THIS MORNING.
SMITH THE COURT ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHT TWENTY
TWO AND PRINT AND OPPOSE THE
HOSTILE AMENDMENTS OF THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
JOHN A PRICE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
pVOTERS AND THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA WE THINK
THE SENATOR FOR THE HARD WORK
THAT HE HAS DONE ON THIS BILL.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY OPPOSED THE
HASSEL AMENDMENTS OR JUST FORCED.
MAUREEN MAHONEY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMERS UNION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT S. B. A TWENTY TWO IN
PRINT AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
WEAKENING AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
MELISSA CAST NETS CENTER FOR
ACCESSIBLE TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT
THE BROADEST PROTECTIONS
POSSIBLE FOR THE OPEN INTERNET
AND THE OF THE BILL AS WRITTEN
OPPOSE THE HOSTILE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
HAVING MAINTENANCE CALIFORNIA
VOICES FOR PROGRESS BEACON ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA THE
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK
CALIFORNIA FOR PESTICIDE REFORM.
THE SACRAMENTO FOOD POLICY
COUNCIL AND THE CALIFORNIA
FARMER JUSTICE COLLABORATIVE WE
ALL SUPPORT AND S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY TWO AND PAN AND OPPOSE
THE HOSTILE AMENDMENTS.
REMIND CALIFORNIA QUEEN MANY
CAMPAIGN SUPPORT IT ESPY TWENTY
TWO IN PRINT AND OPPOSE THE
HOSTILE AMENDMENTS.
JACK BONNER CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE WE SUPPORT THE AUTHOR'S
VERSION OF S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
TWO AND WE OPPOSE THE HOSTILE
MINUTES.
MARCUS YEAH I'M JUST A CITIZEN
FROM DAVIS CALIFORNIA.
AND I CAME HERE TO SUPPORT
THERE'S BE TO I NEED TO THE WAY
IT WAS INTENDED BY WINNER AND
AGAINST DOES WEAKENING
AMENDMENTS --
CRAIG DUNKERLEY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION MEMBERS OF THE COURAGE
CAMPAIGN.
WE SUPPORT THE SBA TWENTY TO THE
AUTHOR'S ORIGINAL VERSION AND
ARE OUTRAGED NOT ONLY AT THE
COMMITTEES A AMENDMENTS BUT THE
WAY THEY WERE ADOPTED.
JOHN KERRY RETIRED ENGINEER
MENLO PARK.
A YEAH I'M PRETTY OUTRAGED BY
THIS ALSO A I SUPPORT.
I CENTER WINNERS ORIGINAL BILL
AND OPPOSE FEES GUTTING OF NET
NEUTRALITY.
LOU DOUGLAS OAKLAND HIGH SUPPORT
THE BILL AS WRITTEN AND STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO DISCUSS THINGS
AMENDMENTS ICY.
SUSAN ARNOUT STOCKTON CALIFORNIA
PEACE AND JUSTICE AND PUTTING
MONEY CAMPAIGN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHT TWENTY TWO WITHOUT
THE HOSTILE AMENDMENTS I'M
DISGUSTED WITH WHAT HAPPENED
HERE TODAY THIS IS REALLY UGLY.
SURELY SHOWING DUSKY FROM
PLEASANT HILL RETIRED PRILIGY IT.
BUY ALSO SUPPORT EIGHT TWENTY
TWO WITHOUT THE HOSTILE
AMENDMENTS I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
MONEY OUT PEOPLE IN.
PLEASE DO THE RIGHT THING.
MY NAME IS VICKI MILLER OLIVEIRA --
HERE FROM SAN HAS I AM JUST A
REGULAR PERSON --
I SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL BILL ON
S. B. TWO EIGHTY EIGHT I'M.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TO YOU I'M
SORRY.
AND BUT I REJECT I'M HAVE TO
REJECT THE AMENDMENTS I A
SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL BILL THE
WAY IT WAS INTENDED TO WEAR A
CERTAIN THING.
MY NAME'S DAVID SCHMIDT.
A BEEN A VOLUNTEER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
FOR THE PAST THIRTEEN YEARS.
I SUPPORT SENATOR WIENERS BILL
THE WAY SENATOR READER WROTE IT.
WITHOUT THE WEAKENING AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CARLA CONFIGURATION
GALA SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
I SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO
WITHOUT THESE OUTRAGEOUS
AMENDMENTS I WANT YOU TO
UNDERSTAND THAT AS A CITIZEN I
AM DEEPLY OFFENDED.
BY THE PERSONALLY I SHOULD SAY
AND POSITION EYEBROW COMMUNITY
THAT WITH EVERYONE I KNOW WE
WILL NOT FORGET WHAT YOU'VE DONE.
FILIATION POSITIONALLY.
HI DON FOG WITH OAKLAND PRIVACY
AND I SUPPORT SENATOR WINNERS
ORIGINAL BILL HOUSE WRITTEN.
AND AM OUTRAGED.
BY WHAT I'VE SEEN HERE.
WE DO NOT SUPPORT THE HOSTILE
AMENDMENTS.
NOW MY NAME IS MARY RYAN I
SUPPORT.
THE BILL AS WRITTEN BY SCOTT
WIENER.
AYE VIOLENTLY OPPOSE.
THE DECISIONS MADE BY THIS COURT
TODAY.
I CANNOT BELIEVE YEARS VOTING
FOR TRUMP BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
YOU'VE DONE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF THE
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND FACULTY
STAFF LIBRARIANS AND COACHES OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS IT IS IN
PRINT.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO VOICE THE
SUPPORT --
FOR THE BILL IN PRINT FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS THANK YOU.
MAY I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION WE
ALSO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AS IN PRINT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSION IT
WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY PROFESSIONALS
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
HOW WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS IN YOU
KNOW IN PRINT VERSION OF THE
BILL THANK YOU?
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JAMES
JACK ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COMPETITIVE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND PRINT
THANK YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSIBLE CHAIR THE CALL
THIS REMAIN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
AND PRINT.
JESSICA BARTOLO WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AS IT IS IN PRINT.
ELLEN CHAPMAN INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO IN CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG WE POSE THE AMENDMENTS
AND SUPPORT THE BILL AS IN PRINT.
JULIE CHAPMAN WITH INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO IN CALIFORNIA STAY
STRONG WE SUPPORT THE BILL AS
PRINTED AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
INAPPROPRIATELY DONE TODAY.
JERRY MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER FOR
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION OF CALIFORNIA AND IT'S ALL
FOR THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS MANY OF THEM IN YOUR
DISTRICTS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE ORIGINAL BILL
THANK YOU [inaudible] FOR
MICHAEL KARSH WHO MOVED TO AMEND
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
TWENTY TWO HAS IT WAS WRITTEN
AND STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION. TO
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE ADOPTED
TO IT WITHOUT EVEN HAVING A
HEARING ON THE AMENDMENTS.
AND A BUCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AS IN PRINT.
AND THE REST EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CAO PARK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS IMPRINTS.
TEAR GAS REPRESENTING OFFICER
REPAIR ADVOCATES WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BALLOT IN PRINT
HOWEVER WE HAVE YET TO REVIEW
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS YOU.
MORNING CARVAJAL WITH THEIR
HERNANDEZ STRATEGY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT NINE
WHEREAS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND PRINT.
MILLION AS FOR THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
WE DO NOT SUPPORT THE COMMITTEES
MANAGED TO THIS BILL WE SUPPORT
THE ORIGINAL S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
TWO BECAUSE IT HELPS COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR.
THE AMENDMENTS TODAY WOULD NOT
SUPPORT THAT COMMITTEE THINK.
DAVID JONES OF HALF OF THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF THE
ORIGINAL BILL.
THANKS.
RONNIE VERTICAL HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
SABAH WE DO NOT HAVE OFFICIALLY
HAVE A POSITION ON A SINNER
WINNERS SBA --
TWENTY TWO MY POLICY COMMITTEE
DID RECOMMENDED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT UNANIMOUS SUPPORT --
POSITION FOR THE BILL THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN PRINT NOT THE
AMENDMENTS --
AND THAT'S THE THAT'S THE BILL
THAT OUR BOARD WILL BE
CONSIDERING IN LATE JUNE --
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT WE HAVE WE
DID SUPPORT HIS HIS ORIGINAL
VERSION OF BILL THINK IT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS WE SUPPORT THAT.
THEIR VERSION OF THE BILL AND
PRINT AND WE OPPOSE THE HOSTILE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MUCH TIGHTER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE VERSION IN PRINT.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE BELIEVE IN NO WAY
PROTECT WORKERS RIGHT TO A FAIR
COMMUNICATION VIA FREE AND OPEN
INTERNET.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
OBSERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
WRITERS GUILD OF AMERICA WEST
TEN OR TEN THOUSAND UNION
MEMBERS WHO WRITE TELEVISION
SHOWS MOVIES DOCUMENTARIES NEWS
PROGRAMS AND ONLINE VIDEO
PROGRAMMING.
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
TWENTY TWO AS IT IS IN PRINT
TODAY THANK YOU?
NICHOLAS HAD ON WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE WITH THE NET
NEUTRALITY IS A CRUCIAL
DEMOCRACY ISSUE.
WE SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL VERSION --
IS INTRODUCED BY THE AUTHOR NOT
THE AMENDMENTS THINKING.
CHEN MEMBERS ON THE OTHER HAND
WITH THE WIDENING GROUP
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SCO YOU ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
SB A TWENTY TO US IS CURRENTLY
IMPRINT NOT THE AMENDMENTS.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN MARS
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT THAT ARE MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS ON IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT TWENTY TWO AS IT IS
IN PRINT AND DO NOT SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KEVIN QUICK ON BEHALF OF BAY
AREA STERN ACTIVISTS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL AS IN PRINT BUT WE
OPPOSE.
P. COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU.
JOHN KREIDLER REPRESENTING
COMPUTER USERS EDUCATORS ARE
TWENTY THOUSAND EDUCATORS IN
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THE BILL
US IN PRINT AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE AMENDMENT.
IRISH PARA CROWTHER CEMETERY
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING COMPUTER
USING EDUCATORS AND I AM ALSO A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WOMAN ON
BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WORKING WITH.
STATE AGENCIES ALL OVER THE
STATE I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHT TWENTY TWO IN PRINT AND
OPPOSED TO THE AMENDMENTS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO
AND COMMITTEE I AM MY NAME IS
MARY BEVINS I'M A TEACHER AND
STEP JUST GONNA FIGHT SCHOOL
DISTRICT A MEMBER OF CT A BOARD
MEMBER OF P. SECTION OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY.
I STRONGLY STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHT TWENTY TWO WITHOUT THE
AMENDMENTS AND PRINT.
HELLO MY NAME IS SARAH CAPACITY
I'M A MEMBER OF INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO.
AND I FEEL VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT.
PROTECTING THAT NEUTRALITY --
AND I WAS VERY HAPPY YOU EVEN
WHEN.
THAT CAN THAT THAT.
CALIFORNIA WAS GOING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT [inaudible]
FEDERAL.
AND I'M I'M VERY TO ME NAME
POSITION AFFILIATION AND
AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE I HAVE
TO SHARE ALL SIDES ON THAT I
SUPPORT EIGHT TWENTY TWO IMPRINT
AND OPPOSE THE HOSTILE GUIDING
AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
WHICH DESTROY NET NEUTRALITY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A MY NAME IS CAROL PENSON I'M --
WITH HEALTHY CALIFORNIA MOVED TO
AMEND CODE PINK.
AND I USE AS STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO WITHOUT A THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED BY THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL KARSH IN
MARTINEZ.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY TWO THE IN PRINT VERSION
AND I STRONGLY A PRO OPPOSE THE
IMPROPERLY ADOPTED AMENDMENTS.
A MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
TONY GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF EDT
SECURITY SERVICES --
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
IN PRINT THANK YOU.
THINK I'M SURE WINNER ON
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU DON'T.
YOU HAVE THIRTY MINUTES HAVE
RECOMMEND TWO MINUTES PER
PRESENTATION BUT YOU CAN USE
THEM AS YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BILL DIVINE AND I
REPRESENT A T. AND T..
A TNT SUPPORTS AN OPEN INTERNET.
WE DO NOT BLOCK WEBSITES WE DO
NOT CENSOR ONLINE CONTENT AND WE
DO NOT DEGRADE INTERNET TRAFFIC.
THESE COMMITMENTS ARE PUBLISHED
ON OUR WEBSITE.
THERE ARE ENFORCEABLE BY THE FCC
THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION AND
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I AM HERE TODAY TO OPPOSE A NET
NEUTRALITY LEGISLATION AND
SPECIFICALLY S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY TWO WHICH GOES
BEYOND [inaudible]
OBAMA'S FCC ORDER.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATION
SENATOR WIENER IS PROPOSING WILL
HARM CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND
DAMAGE THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS THE
INTERNET HAS BEEN THE MAJOR
ENGINE FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
TECHNOLOGICAL LEADERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES.
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE THE INDUSTRY
INVESTS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR.
IN INFRASTRUCTURE RESULTING IN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS
AND THE DEPLOYMENT OF HIGH SPEED
INTERNET TO VIRTUALLY EVERY
CALIFORNIA.
AS WE LOOK TO THE FUTURE.
WE ARE ON THE THRESHOLD OF A
SECOND TECHNOLOGY WAVE WITH THE
INVENTION AND THE DEPLOYMENT OF
FIVE G. WIRELESS TECHNOLOGY.
GIGABIT SPEEDS OVER FIBER.
AND THE INTERNET OF THINKS.
WE OPPOSE EIGHTEEN EIGHT TWENTY
TWO BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT BECOME IT
WILL BECOME A BARRIER TO
DEPLOYING THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO DOES NOT
REINSTATE THE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN OBAMA FCC RULES RATHER
IT GOES FAR BEYOND.
LET ME HIGHLIGHT A NUMBER OF
THOSE ISSUES.
EARLIER YOU HEARD CONVERSATION
ABOUT INNER CONNECTION S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO WOULD BAN LONG
STANDING COMMERCIALLY NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS BETWEEN ISPS AND
CONTENT PROVIDERS AND REYES
CONSUMER PRICES.
S. B. A TWENTY TWO WOULD SHIFT
THESE CALLS FROM MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR CONTENT COMPANIES. TO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
HERE'S WHAT THE OBAMA FCC SAID
ABOUT THIS ISSUE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND I QUOTE.
THIS ORDER DOES NOT APPLY THE
OPEN INTERNET RULES TO INNER
CONNECTION UNQUOTE.
THE FCC WORK ON TO WRITE AGAIN A
QUOTE WE CONCLUDE THAT IT WOULD
BE PREMATURE. TO ADOPT
PRESCRIPTIVE RULES TO ADDRESS
ANY PROBLEMS THAT HAVE ARISEN OR
MAY ARISE UNQUOTE.
MEMBERS IT IS ABSOLUTELY CLEAR
THAT THE OBAMA FCC DID NOT
PROHIBIT ISPS LONGSTANDING
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS. ZERO
RATINGS A SECOND ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN RAISED S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
TWO WOULD AND POPULAR CONSUMER
DRIVEN ZERO RATING PROGRAMS.
ENDING FREE DATA INCENTIVES FOR
CONSUMERS.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ESPECIALLY
POPULAR WITH YOUNG MINORITY AND
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
A RECENT STUDY WHICH YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD DISCUSSED.
HAS IDENTIFIED THAT AT LEAST
THREE POINT SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIA USERS [inaudible]
ENJOY.
FREE DATA ZERO RATING AND THEY
ARE SAVING UPWARDS OF THIRTY
DOLLARS A MONTH.
WITH THESE THREE DATA PROGRAMS
IF YOU WERE TO PASS SB EIGHT
TWENTY TWO IT WOULD BAN ZERO
RATING AND THREE POINT SIX
MILLION CUSTOMERS WHAT EITHER
CHANGE THEIR VIEWING PRACTICES
OR SEE A PRICE INCREASE IN THEIR
BILLS.
IN JANUARY.
THE OBAMA FCC LOOKED CLOSELY AT
THIS ISSUE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN AND SPECIFICALLY DID NOT
PROHIBIT. ZERO RATING.
PROCUREMENT IS ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT IS IN BOTH BILLS.
THE OBAMA NET NEUTRALITY RULES
DID NOT INCLUDE FEDERAL STATE OR
LOCAL PROCUREMENT [inaudible]
PERIOD.
REQUIRING STATE AGENCY TO
INCLUDE NET NEUTRALITY
REQUIREMENTS IN THE PROCUREMENT
PROCESS WHAT HAD COMPLEXITY.
AND LITIGATION TO AN ALREADY
SLOW AND CUMBERSOME PROCESS.
THE RESULT WILL BE ADDITIONAL
DELAY IN DEPLOYING THE MOST
ADVANCED INFORMATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES.
WHO SERVE YOUR CONSTITUENTS?
AND FINALLY THERE IS THE ISSUE
AND THE CONFUSION THAT IS BEING
SOLD ON PREEMPTION.
BOTH THE OBAMA TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN ORDER.
AND THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FCC ORDER INCLUDED FEDERAL
PREEMPTION.
IN THEIR NET NEUTRALITY ORDER.
EVEN FCC CHAIRMAN TOM WHEELER
WHO SOMEONE SPOKE OF EARLIER
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF A
NATIONAL POLICY.
HE READ HE RECOGNIZED THE
INTERNIST INTERNET IS AN
INTERSTATE SERVICE.
IN THE COMMISSION'S ORDER AND I
QUOTE.
HE WANTS TO REAFFIRM THE
COMMISSION'S LONG STANDING
CONCLUSIONS THAT BROADBAND
INTERNET ACCESS SERVICE IS
JURISDICTION ONLY INTERSTATE.
FOR REGULATORY PURPOSES THOSE
ARE THE WORDS OF THE FCC CHAIRED
BY TOM WHEELER.
SO MEMBERS IN CONCLUSION.
THIS BILL S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO
IS TOO EXTREME.
IT GOES FAR BEYOND THE FCC'S TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN ORDER UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
AND THERE HAS BEEN NO
PRESENTATION OF ANY EVIDENCE
THAT THERE IS AN ACTUAL PROBLEM.
I ASK THAT YOU THINK ABOUT YOUR
OWN SURFING ON THE WEB YOUR OWN
ENQUIRIES IN THE INTERNET YOU'RE
NOT BLOCKED YOU CAN GO ANYWHERE.
ANYTIME ON THE INTERNET AND
GATHER ANY INFORMATION YOU
CHOOSE TO LOOK AT WE BELIEVE A
TWENTY TWO IS IT ANTI CONSUMER
AND WILL DRIVE UP THE COST.
SERVICE FOR INTERNET SERVICE
EIGHT TWENTY TO CREATE A
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE AND
LITIGATION.
ENVIRONMENT THAT HARMS
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND
WEEKENDS WEEKENDS CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP.
IN THE TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION
GOING FORWARD.
WE WOULD URGE THE MEMBERS TO
VOTE NO ON NET NEUTRALITY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CAROLINE MCINTYRE AND BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
TWENTY TWO AS IN PLANT.
TWENTY TWO AS AMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
AND WE'RE HERE TALKING ABOUT NET
NEUTRALITY GIVEN THE ACTION THAT
WAS TAKEN BY THE FCC IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHERE THEY
MOVED TO REPLACE THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN FCC ORDER.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT AT
FIRST OF ALL.
ALL OF MY MEMBER COMPANIES
ADHERE TO THE POLICIES AND THE
PRINCIPLES OF AN OPEN INTERNET.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT WE ARE NOT WITHOUT
REGULATORY STRUCTURE AT THIS
POINT THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
CURRENTLY IN PLACE THAT GOVERNS
OUR ACTIVITIES ON THE INTERNET.
IS THE SAME REGULATORY STRUCTURE
THAT HAS BEEN IN PLACE AND WHY
THAN PLACE UP UNTIL.
TWENTY FIFTEEN IT IS THE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK UNDER WE
BROWN AND THRIVE AND BECOME THE
TOOL THAT WE KNOW IT TO BE TODAY.
SO WE DON'T SEE A NEED TO HAVE
STATES IMPOSING ADDITIONAL
REGULATION HERE ON A SERVICES
MISTER DEVINE POINTED OUT THAT
IS IN INTERSTATE SERVICE AND
SHOULD BE GOVERNED BY ONE SET OF
REGULATIONS AND THE FRAMEWORK.
THAT IS IN FACT CURRENTLY IN
PLACE WE BELIEVE THE STATE'S ARE
PREEMPTED IN THIS SPACE THERE
WILL LIKELY RESULT IN.
SIGNIFICANT LITIGATION AND THAT
TOO WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
OPERATIONS OF OUR INTERNET IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA UNTIL
THOSE ISSUES ARE RESOLVED.
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT AS
WRITTEN THE BILL WOULD ALLOW NOT
ONLY BE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL BUT IT WOULD ALLOW FIFTY
EIGHT DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
CITY ATTORNEYS AND JOHN DOE
CITIZENS TO BRING LAWSUITS.
ALL OF THOSE JURISDICTIONS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO MAKE THEIR OWN
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT THESE
PROHIBITIONS ARE IN THIS BILL
SUBJECTING US. TO VARIOUS TYPES
OF AB I HAVE AB PROSECUTIONS
[inaudible]
I AM.
BASED ON THE DEFINITION OF
WHOEVER HAPPENS TO BE IN CHARGE.
LASTLY THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
S. B. EIGHT TWO TWO WAS IN FACT
ATTEMPTING TO RE CODIFY THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER.
IT WAS NOT A GOES BEYOND THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER IN FACT IN
ITS CURRENT VERSION IT STILL
GOES BEYOND THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
ORDER BY HAVING SO MANY
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND BY
INCLUDING THE PROHIBITIONS.
ON PROCUREMENT I HAVE WITH ME
HERE TODAY RECTAL CANCER IS A
PARTNER WITH THE LAW FIRM OF
WELCOME THING BAKER AND OUR HE
HAS BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THE
COMMUNICATION SPACE AS AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE FCC.
BUT MORE RECENTLY HE WAS
ACTUALLY INVOLVED IN THE NET
NEUTRALITY PROCEEDINGS THAT TOOK
PLACE AT THE FCC.
ON THE TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER AND
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN ORDER
[inaudible]
AFTER ABOUT.
NUMBER OKAY CAN ORDER OKAY AND
THAT AND THAT.
TWENTY THOU THOU I BASS MISTER
HOUSER HERE TODAY TO JOIN ME SO
THAT HE CAN ACTUALLY SPEAK TO
THE PROVISIONS HAVE EIGHT TO TWO
THAT WERE NOT.
A PART ADD THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
FCC ORDER SO IF YOU WOULD ALLOW
ME MISTER CHAIRMAN I'D LIKE TO
HAND OFF TO MISTER HOW YOU
ANSWER.
YOU CAN USE YOUR THIRTY MINUTES
OF THE WAY YOU WANT AMBER I
RECOMMEND TWO MINUTES HOWEVER
USING HOW YOU WANT.
THINK WE'RE GONNA GO.
I THAT THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU CAROLYN AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY.
SAW SO THE DAY THIS IS THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN FCC ORDER WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT AYE THE DAY
CAME OUT HAVING WORKED ON YOU ON
A FOR VARIOUS KINDS OF PRINT IT
OUT.
I LAY DOWN ON THE FLOOR OF MY
OFFICE AND TO COVER POP PROBABLY
FOR THE TWO YEARS AFTER THAT I
THAT WASN'T TOO DAY THAT WENT BY
WITHOUT HAVING TO CONSULT IT.
AYE AYE.
YOU KNOW IT'S NO IT'S NO FIFTY
SHADES OF GRAY BUT IT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S IT'S OF WORK I KNOW
WELL --
THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS IN WHICH
THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF I SP
EIGHT TWENTY TWO WENT WELL
BEYOND WHAT THIS ORDER SAID I
WANT TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS A COUPLE
OF THEM THAT THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT.
SO I'LL START WITH YOUR RATING.
THERE ARE TWO WAYS IN WHICH THE
ORIGINAL BILL WENT BEYOND.
THE FCC'S TWENTY FIFTEEN
DECISION WITH REGARD TO YOUR
RATING.
FIRST BY ADOPTING PACIFIC
SUBSTANTIVE MANDATE WHEN THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER REFUSED TO
DO THAT AND SECOND BY FOR
BIDDING ACTUAL ACTIVITY THAT
EVEN THE WHEELER A BOMB FCC DID
NOT THAT DID NOT BAN.
SO FIRST THE THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF THE BILL ADOPTED A
RULE SETTING OUT A SUBSTANTIVE
STANDARD WITH RESPECT IS YOUR
RATING.
THAT IS WHAT IS ALLOWED WHAT'S
NOT ALLOWED WHEN THE FCC HAD
EXPRESSLY REFUSED TO DO SO.
IT HELD A PARAGRAPH ONE FIFTY
ONE OF THIS ORDER THAT THE
RECORD REFLECTED MIXED VIEWS
ABOUT YOUR RATING AND SPONSOR
DATA PLANS.
IF RECOGNIZE RECORD EVIDENCE
THAT SUCH ARRANGEMENTS QUOTE MAY
IN SOME INSTANCES PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO CONSUMERS CITING
ARGUMENTS THAT THESE BUSINESS
MODELS INCREASE CHOICE AND LOWER
COSTS FOR CONSUMERS.
GIVEN THE MIX EVIDENCE IN THE
RECORD THE FCC EXPLICITLY
DECLINED TO ADOPT A RULE.
I INDEED IN A TWENTY SIXTEEN
INTERVIEW WITH THE ONLINE
PUBLICATION THE VERGE CHAIRMAN
WHEELER SAID WE ARE QUITE
SPECIFIC IN THE OPEN INTERNET
ORDER ARE SAYING WE WEREN'T
GOING TO ADDRESS YOUR RATING.
BECAUSE WE COULD ARGUE IT BOTH
WAYS YOU CAN SEE WHERE IT'S
HELPFUL IF IT REDUCES COST
INCREASES CHOICE THOSE WERE
CHAIRMAN WHEELERS WORDS AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN SO THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN ORDER REFUSED TO DOT
JUST SIT.
RUINS YOUR RATING --
AT PARAGRAPH ONE FIFTY TWO OF
YOUR EMPHASIZE THAT WOULD LOOK
AT AN ASSESSMENT PRACTICES UNDER
WHAT IT CALLED THE NO ONE
REASONABLE INTERFERENCE OR
DISADVANTAGE STANDARD.
WHAT'S SOMETIMES CALLED THE
GENERAL CONDUCT STANDARD --
THAT'S STANDARD STATES THAT NICE
PIECE ON NOT UNREASONABLY
INTERFERE WITH RUN REASONABLY
DISADVANTAGE AND USERS ABILITY
TO SELECT ACCESS AND USE
BROADBAND INTERNET SERVICE --
TERRORISTS HAD OUR OUT WERE EDGE
PROVIDERS ABILITY TO MAKE LAWFUL
CONTENT APPLICATIONS ARE DEVICES
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO ALL END
USERS.
WHAT'S CRITICAL HERE IS THAT
SECTION ONE SEVEN SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SIX EIGHT OF THE
ORIGINAL SB --
SEVEN SB TWENTY TWO IS VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL TO THAT FCC RULE THAT
IS IF YOU WANTED A BILL THAT
WOULD MATCH WITH THE FCC DID ON
YOUR RATING WHAT YOU DO IS ADOPT
A BILL THAT HAD. SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SIX EIGHT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THAT BILL OR AS ORIGINALLY
PRESENTED DID INSTEAD IT WENT
FURTHER ADOPTED A SPECIFIC SUB
DIFFERENT PART ON TOP OF THAT.
BY DEFINITION IT WENT FARTHER.
THE SECOND WAY IN WHICH A TWENTY
TWO WENT BEYOND THE FCC DECISION
IS THAT EXPRESSLY PRECLUDES SOME
ACTIVITY THAT THE OBAMA ERA FCC.
UNDER CHAIRMAN WHEELER DID NOT
FAR SO I'LL OFFER A VERY
CONCRETE EXAMPLE S. B. TWENTY
TWO YOU ARE AS ORIGINALLY
PRESENTED COMPLETELY BARRED YOUR
RATING OF A CONTEMPLATED
OFFERINGS.
IF THE CONTENT PROVIDER PAID THE
I. S. P. IN CONNECTION WITH THAT
YOU'RE RATING.
THAT'S A PRACTICE THAT'S KNOWN
IN THE INDUSTRY IS SPONSORED
DATA THE IDEA IS ESSENTIALLY HEY
IF I'M A KIND TO PROVIDER I WANT
PEOPLE TO USE MY STUFF.
I'M GONNA OFFSET YOUR COSTS FOR
DATA I'M GONNA POTENTIALLY PAID
OF CONTEMPT THAT THE EYES
INSTEAD OF YOU --
IS A RELATIVELY ELLIPSES AT
LEAST NOT AN UNCOMMON PRACTICE
THE FCC TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER
EXPRESSLY REFUSED TO BAR SPONSOR
DATA ARRANGEMENTS AGAIN A
PARAGRAPH ONE FIFTY ONE IT'S
SAID THAT THOSE.
DATE THOSE ARRANGEMENTS
INCREASED CHOICE AND LOWER COSTS
FOR CONSUMERS --
SO SO WHEN IT IS SO IN SUMMARY
ON THAT --
THIS A TWENTY TWO IS REALLY
PLANTED BARRED THE THING THAT
THE FCC SAID IT WANTED OF YOU IN
A CASE BY CASE BASIS OKAY.
NO RETURNED INTERCONNECTION I'M.
ALSO KNOWN AS TRAFFIC EXCHANGE
SO THAT WE FIRST THE HANDOFF OF
TRAFFICKING OF DEEP INSIDE THE
INTERNET NOT THE LAST MILE PIPES
THAT THE THE EYES PEAS OPERATE
ITEM WHEN YOU.
WHEN YOU BUY BROADBAND INTERNET
ACCESS SERVICE FROM THEM BUT
UPSTREAM TO WHAT YOU MIGHT THINK
OF IS KIND OF THE LARGER
ARTERIES OF THE CIRCULATORY
SYSTEM OF THE INTERNET?
I'M HERE TO THE BILL SETS FORTH
THE BILL'S ORIGINALLY PRESENTED
AS WRITTEN SET FORTH A
SUBSTANTIVE REQUIREMENTS
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX
I WOULD MAKE IT UNLAWFUL FOR
HIGHEST PEATED ENGAGE IN
PRACTICE WITH RESPECT.
TO RELATED TO IT ISP TRAFFIC TO
CHANGE THE HAVE THE PER.
THE FCC IN CONTRAST EXPRESSLY
DECLINED TO ADOPT SUCH ARBITRARY
REQUIREMENT IN FACT CHAIRMAN
WHEELERS ORDER I SAID OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT WOULD NOT ADOPT
THAT IT'S HAD A PARAGRAPH ONE
NINETY FIVE SAYING THAT WE
CONCLUDE THAT APPLICATION OF OUR
RULES HERE.
I WOULD BE WOOD IS NOT WARRANTED
WITH RESPECT INTERNET TRAFFIC
CHANGED ITS OTHER PARAGRAPH TWO
OH TWO SAYING IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE OR NECESSARY TO
SUBJECT ARRANGEMENTS FOR IN THAT
TRAFFIC IT CHANGED. TO THE OPEN
INTERNET RULES IT SENATOR
PARAGRAPH TO A SIX AGAIN TO BE
CLEAR WE ARE NOT APPLYING THE
OPEN INTERNET RULES WE DOT TODAY
TO INTERNET TRAFFIC EXCHANGE.
SO THERE'S A CLEAR DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A REGIME IN WHICH THE
REGULATOR MERELY ASSERT ITS
AUTHORITY AS THE FCC DIDN'T
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND ONE THAT
ESTABLISHES SUBSTANTIVE RULES
THAT THE FCC.
I IN FACT NEVER EXERCISED IN THE
TWO YEARS DURING WHICH THAT
ORDER WHAT WAS IN EFFECT
[inaudible]
I'M.
I'VE ALSO SEEN SUGGESTIONS THAT
ON THIS POINT THAT THE ACT THAT
THE FCC WAS GOING TO REVIEW
EVERY INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENT
CASE BY CASE.
THAT'S JUST NOT SO HOT WHAT IT
SAID IT WAS A MEAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO REVIEW DISPUTES
THAT WERE BROUGHT TO IT BY
PARTIES.
AGAIN THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A REGULAR THAT SITS AND
LOOKS AT EVERY SINGLE INSTANCE
OF AN AGREEMENT COMES YOU FOR IT.
PROBABLY NOT PRACTICAL IT ANYWAY
IN ANY CASE AND EVERY GENE WHICH
THE FCC SAID WILL BE A JUDGE OF
SOMEONE HAS HAS A PROBLEM --
WITH THAT I WIL --
SEE THE FLOOR AND WAIT FOR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AGAIN CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STEVE CARLSON.
YEAH THE WIRELESS.
I JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE
A FIFTEEN MINUTES THANK YOU.
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT NOT ONLY DO WE
OPPOSE HAS BE EIGHT TWENTY TWO
AS WRITTEN.
WE OPPOSE AS BE A TWENTY TWO AS
AMENDED TODAY.
BUTTONS NOT A SUGGESTION THAT WE
BELIEVE WELL AS SOME OF THE
WITNESSES HAVE INDICATED THAT
THE SAYS OF HISTORY TO NET
NEUTRALITY FAR BEYOND THAT WE
BELIEVE THE BILL EVEN AS AMENDED.
GOES BEYOND THE TWENTY FIFTEEN A
BOMB ORDER AND WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT OF THE STATE BY
STATE REGULATION OF THE INTERNET.
IS INAPPROPRIATE --
AND THE THE ROOM RARELY DO THAT --
THE FALLACY AT THE HEART OF S.
B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO OR EVEN THE
BILL AS AMENDED.
UP IS THE FALSE PRESUMPTION THAT
ONE SIDE OF NET NEUTRALITY
DEBATE ACTUALLY OPPOSES AND OPEN
INTERNET.
THAT IS FALSE --
THE UNCERTAINTY CREATED BY THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN OBAMA ORDER WHICH
IS.
SIMILAR TO BUT NOT IDENTICAL TO
THE BILL AS AS AMENDED THIS
MORNING.
BECAUSE THE MOBILE BROADBAND
INDUSTRY. TO REDUCE ITS
INVESTMENT IN MOBILE BROADBAND
BY SIX POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY [inaudible]
THAT'S BILLION.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE
UNCERTAINTY CREATED BY --
THESE THE RULES THAT ARE WE
BELIEVE ARE NECESSARY --
WE TALKED ABOUT MISTER WHEELER
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF A
SINGLE NATIONAL REGULATORY MODEL --
BUT WE DON'T BELIEVE.
THE FEAR OF UNREALIZED HARM.
BE THE BASIS FOR ENACTING LAWS
THAT WILL CURB THE NEXT
GENERATION OF DIGITAL INNOVATION.
AS BE A TWENTY TWO IN ITS
ORIGINAL FORMAT DO THAT AND BY
THE WAY WE BELIEVE.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO AS
AMENDED WILL STILL DO THAT --
BROADBAND PROVIDERS TO A GREATER
EXTENT THAN ALMOST EVERY
STAKEHOLDER HAVE COMMITTED TO
RESPECTING AND PROTECTING THE
OPEN INTERNET.
ALARMIST SPECULATION TO THE
CONTRARY AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
CONTRARY.
DOESN'T SUPPORT A RADICAL
DEPARTURE FROM THE TRENCH
TRADITIONAL LIKE REGULATORY
APPROACH.
THE FACTS ARE CLEAR OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES HAVE PUBLICLY
COMMITTED NOT TO BLOCK THROTTLE
OR AND COMPETITIVELY.
PRIORITIZE INTERNET TRAFFIC
WHILE ACTING WITH TRANSPARENCY
IN WHAT THEY DO.
PLEASE DO NOT LET RHETORIC AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S THE
RHETORIC IN TERMS OF HARM THAT
WE'VE HEARD TODAY.
TRIUMPH OVER REALITY.
THE ONLY TANGIBLE COST WILL BE
TO THE PEOPLE AND INNOVATORS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL OF
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CERTAINLY RECEIVE AT AVENUE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT ARE
GOING -- TO
COUNTER TWENTY MINUTES.
THEN I AT THIS POINT I'LL CALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY AND I WILL STOP IF
YOU GO BEYOND THAT.
MY NAME IS SO KEY HOLE AND WITH
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ASSOCIATION A POP UP.
APOP OPPOSES SP.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO ERIC HARRIS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE NAACP
IN OPPOSITION.
SO CHAIRMAN MACHINE LEVINE ON
BEHALF OF COMCAST'S OPPOSED TO
THE ORIGINAL VERSION S. B. TWO
TWO IN THE CURRENT VERSION
AMENDED VERSIONS WILL THANK.
ILANA BENTSEN ABOUT AT THE HALF
OF CHALCONE --
OPPOSED TO EIGHT TWENTY TWO AND
CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED EVEN WITH
THE AMENDMENTS.
JACKIE KENNY FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL EVEN WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
SHARE MEMBERS LARA BUT IT WITH
TECH NET WE HAVE AN OPPOSE LET'S
POSIT AND LEFT A MINUTE POSITION
TO THE BILL IN PRINT IN AS MUCH
OF THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
ALONG WITH IT TWENTY FIFTEEN
ORDER WE WOULD BE PREPARED TO GO
NEUTRAL GOTTA REMIND YOU THAT
NAME AFFILIATION A POSITIONAL.
GOOD MORNING BRENDA PALOMINO
HERE ON BEHALF OF SPRINT ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
HAD HE PERSONALLY ON BEHALF OF
VERIZON IN OPPOSITION.
SUSAN PETERSON LEPER ON BEHALF
OF T. MOBILE IN OPPOSITION.
DON'T AFFECT USUALLY HAVE TO
CHARTER COMMUNICATIONS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL IN PRINT AND THE
MINUTES.
PAM LIMITS ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS IN
OPPOSITION.
Q. CARMONA WITH*
COMMUNICATIONS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY BARRIERS SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
AZIZA DAVIS GOINGS OUT WITH THE
SACRAMENTO BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION.
KATHY RODRIGUEZ WITH THE
SACRAMENTO HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION.
SHERRI FLANAGAN ON BEHALF OF
SOCIETY FOR THE BLIND AND WE
OPPOSE SB.
EIGHT TWENTY DRILL COOK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE.
NANCY MARRIAGE WITH THE CONGRESS
OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ERIC
JOHNSON PAST PRESENT PRESIDENT
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE TO
SHARE THE CHAMBERS OPPOSITION TO
SB A TWENTY TWO CABINET MEMBERS
TOPIC TOMORROW HOW BEHALF TO SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALSO IN.
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DOING
COMMITTEE PRESIDENT CEO
CALIFORNIA SPENDING CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE OPPOSED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SHAW HAWKING
* COMMUNICATIONS IN
OPPOSITION.
THE ANY TALK AS SACRAMENTO ASIAN
PACIFIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION.
LET SHEPHERD FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASIA PACIFIC ISLANDER CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE RESPECTFULLY NOT
POSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN
DORY AND HAVE THE CIVIL JUSTICE
SOLUTION TO CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
HALLOWEEN THERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALLIANCE OF
VENTURA AND SANTA BARBARA
COUNTIES OPPOSED.
WE THINK OUR SIENNA PRESENTING
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF HISPANIC
REALTORS AND WHERE OPPOSE BOTH
BILLS.
NAME IS MARKUS GOMEZ AND I
REPRESENT MY COMPANY CALIFORNIA.
CLOTHING RECYCLERS AND WE OPPOSE
SP FOUR SIXTY AN S. B..
EIGHT TWO TWO GOOD MORNING
LINDANE REPRESENTING OC
SACRAMENTAL ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN.
ADVOCATES WE OPPOSE BOTH S. B.
FOR SIXTY AN S. B. EIGHT TO TO
LOOK.
DARIA CUTS AGO REPRESENTING
RUSSIAN AMERICAN MEDIA WE BOTH
OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO
AND AS BEFORE.
SIXTY GARY MCDONALD LIGHTHOUSE.
COUNSELLING AND FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
ALSO SERVE ON THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE FOR
LINCOLN CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE --
SP EIGHT TWENTY TWO AM EST
BEFORE.
THANK YOU MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL
IN OPPOSITION.
KEVIN WILL CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY ACTION FUND CAME
HERE TO SUPPORT THE BILLBUT NOW
MUST OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE THE
OUTRAGEOUS AMENDMENTS THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS ADDED TO IT.
ANGELA BANG WITH ASIA RESOURCES
INCORPORATED WE OPPOSE SP FOUR
SIXTY AND SB. EIGHTY TWO I THINK
AT THIS POINT TIME WE UNLESS
THERE'S ANY OF THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION --
IT WOULD BE I AM GOING TO GO TO
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN START --
I'M WITHDRAWING THE BILL FROM
COMMITTEE CONSIDERATION IN THIS
HEARING I DON'T WANT TO VOTE
TODAY ON THIS BILL.
OP MORE OF A STATEMENT YOU KNOW
THIS IS A VERY EMOTIONAL ISSUE
AS A VERY POLITICIZED ISSUE.
AND I JUST WANTED TO TALK FOR A
MINUTE ABOUT.
WHAT NET NEUTRALITY IS BECAUSE I
THINK THAT WE DO A DISSERVICE TO
THE ISSUE IF WE DON'T?
A TAKE A NON EMOTIONAL
INTELLECTUAL APPROACH TO DEBATE.
I WHEN WE USE EMOTIONALLY LOADED
TERMS LIKE --
WOULD NEUTRALITY IS A GOOD ONE
BUT AN OPEN FREE INTERNET WHO
WOULD BE AGAINST THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THAT'S WHAT LEADS TO
SOME OF THE EMOTIONAL CHARGE BUT
ALSO.
IN OUR PRESENTATIONS HERE WE'VE
HEARD SOME VERY PROVOCATIVE
THINGS AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT FOR A SECOND BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK ANYONE.
IS TALKING ABOUT --
OF SCHOOL HAVING TO PAY INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDER SO THAT PARENTS
COULD GO ONLINE TO GET THEIR
CHILDREN'S.
ACADEMIC RECORDS I MEAN I I
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER NOT THAT
WAS AGAINST THE LAW.
ANY INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER
THE TRIED TO DO THAT WOULD HAVE
A WHOLESALE DEFECTION OF THEIR
ENTIRE CUSTOMER BASE AND NO ONE
IS TALKING ABOUT DOING THAT.
SO WHEN MY CONSTITUENTS COME TO
BE AN ASK TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT NET NEUTRALITY I USE A
METAPHOR AND MAYBE BE HELPFUL.
SO WHAT I TALK ABOUT IS A
VILLAGE BESIDE A RIVER
[inaudible]
AND A A BRIDGE OPERATOR BUILDS A
BRIDGE OVER THE RIVER TO THE
VILLAGE WHICH IS GREATLY
BENEFICIAL TO THE PEOPLE THAT
LIVE THERE.
BUT TO RECOVER THE COSTS OF
CONSTRUCTING THE BRIDGE IN
OPERATING THE BRIDGE THE BRIDGE
OPERATOR INSTITUTE TOLLS ON THAT
BRIDGE.
SO THE QUESTION IS.
IF YOU WANT TO DRIVE AN EIGHTEEN
WHEELER OVER THE BRIDGE SHOULD
THEY PAY THE SAME TOLL AS A
HONDA CIVIC.
AND IF YOU THINK THAT THEY
SHOULD THEN YOU'RE.
A PROPONENT OF BRIDGE NEUTRALITY
RIGHT YOU THINK ALL TRAFFIC
SHOULD BE TREATED THE SAME.
HEALTH PRETEND FURTHER THAT THE
BRIDGE OPERATOR WANTS TO CREATE
A ARE A FAST TRACK CLEAN.
WHERE YOU CAN PAY? TO BE ABLE TO
USE THIS LANGUAGE BY THE WAY
BENEFITS ALL THE USERS OF THE
BRIDGE BECAUSE DIVERT TRAFFIC
AWAY FROM THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
WILLING TO PAY THAT HIGHER TOLL
THAT'S THAT'S PAID
PRIORITIZATION.
CAPE SO.
I WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THIS YOU
KNOW THAT I I'VE WHEN I THINK
ABOUT THE SPENT FOR HAVE A HARD
TIME.
JUSTIFYING WHY THAT'S NOT AN
OKAY THING TO DO.
AND THE ONLY ARGUMENT AGAINST
THAT THAT RESONATES TO ME.
IS THAT MAYBE IT GIVES THE
BRIDGE OPERATOR.
AN UNFAIR AMOUNT OF CONTROL OVER
THE AMOUNT OF TRAFFIC THAT GOES
INTO THE VILLAGE RIGHT OF THE
BRIDGE OPERATOR DID SOMETHING
OUTRAGEOUS LIKE.
PROHIBITING TRUCKS THAT HAD BEEN
AND AS IN THEM.
WE COULD SAY LEGITIMATELY WHILE
IT'S NOT FAIR FOR THE BRIDGE
OPERATOR TO DETERMINE WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO EAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHICH IS AGENDA SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN SAID IN
AND IN THIS DEBATE.
BUT THE ONLY THING THAT'S
REQUIRED. TO PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING.
IS MORE BRIDGES.
THERE'S A BRIDGE A MILE DOWN THE
RIVER.
THAN ANYONE HAS BEEN AND AS IN
THEIR TRUCK IF THEY WERE TO DO
SOMETHING OUTRAGEOUS LIKE THAT
THEY WOULD GO USE A DIFFERENT
BRIDGE.
AND HERE'S THE BIG PROBLEM THAT
I HAVE WITH WITH.
THIS ISSUE IN GENERAL NET
NEUTRALITY IN GENERAL IS THAT
THE MORE.
OPPRESSIVE REGULATION THAT WE
LATER ON INDUSTRY THE LAST
BRIDGES THAT WE GET.
AND OF MORE BRIDGES IS VERY
BENEFICIAL TO OUR SOCIETY THAT
SOLVES A WHOLE HOST OF PROBLEMS
INCLUDING A LOT OF THE ONES THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP.
IN DEBATE TODAY BUT ONE
IMPORTANT ONE THAT HASN'T AND
THAT IS FAIR PRICING.
YOU GET FAIR PRICING FOR FREE IF
YOU HAVE LOTS OF BRIDGES.
AND THAT'S WHY.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS AN
INTELLECTUAL WAY I CAN'T BE A
SUPPORTER OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
IN THE BILL TODAY EVEN AS
AMENDED?
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
HM I DID JUST MAKE A STATEMENT
BEFORE ABOUT WITHDRAWING THE
BILL CONSIDERATION --
TODAY AT THIS HEARING.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
I'D.
MADE A REQUIRED JUST INDICATED
THAT IT WAS WITHDRAWING THE BILL
FROM CONSIDERATION OF TODAY'S
HEARING.
I'M DISAPPOINTED --
BUT YOU'RE DOING THIS --
YOU AND I HAVE GONE BACK AND
FORTH ON US.
AND WE STAYED UP EXTREMELY LATE.
AND STARTED VERY EARLY THIS
MORNING [inaudible]
AND LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
WHAT HAPPENED.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS NOT A
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN ANY
DEBATE.
AND TO PUT FORTH.
AMENDMENTS TO A COMMITTEE
WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
THE COMMITTEE'S INPUT.
IT'S A BIT UNFAIR --
OUR PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
WERE THE EXACT [inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN OBAMA RULE.
AS AS WRITTEN.
BUT BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
VERY VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING.
AND THAT WOULD SET A FOUNDATION.
FOR A CONVERSATION. TO CONTINUE.
FOR I MEAN THIS IS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
IT'S ABOUT A DEBATE.
IT'S ABOUT GIVE AND TAKE.
IT'S ABOUT COMING. TO A PRODUCT.
THAT DOES WHAT WE THINK IT
SHOULD DO.
NOW YOU KNOW I BOTH AGREE.
THAT WE NEED A NOT ENTIRELY
NEUTRALITY BILL.
AND I WANT A NET NEUTRALITY BILL
[inaudible]
BUT PUT FORTH.
A FEW PAGES.
AND SAY THIS MIRRORS. FOUR
HUNDRED PAGES.
OF WHAT I INTERPRET.
AS AN FCC RULE.
IT'S A BIT UNFAIR TO WILL
COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE WE NEED THE BENEFIT THE
ALSO [inaudible]
START THIS [inaudible]
THIS CONVERSATION.
I'M WILLING TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE.
BUT I THINK IT'S A BIT UNFAIR.
TO ASSUME THAT THIS COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
I SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN PUT
NOW.
I'D LIKE TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION.
AND I THINK YOU SHOULD.
AT THE PLATFORM TO JUST BEGIN
THIS CONVERSATION.
NOW WE CAN COME TO AN AGREEMENT
OF THE CLASS --
WHEW THE PAST MIDNIGHT AND WE
STARTED PRETTY EARLY --
AND LET'S BE CLEAR.
WE HAVE FOUGHT IN PUSH BACK ON
INDUSTRY. TO GET A NET
NEUTRALITY BILL AND EVERY MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I CAN'T SPEAK THE REPUBLICANS
EXPECT FOR THE DEMOCRATS ARE
COMMITTED.
THE GETTING OUT INTO TO IT NEXT
HOLIDAY BILL AND WORKING WITH
YOU [inaudible]
BUT WE BOTH UNDERSTAND.
HOW THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WORKS THE COMMITTEE RECOMMENDS
AMENDMENTS?
NOT THE MEMBERS COMING TO A
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
NOW.
HAVING SAID THAT I THINK YOU
STILL HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS.
YOU CAN CHOOSE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION OR YOU CAN CHOOSE
NOT TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUING A
CONVERSATION.
AND IT'S BUT IT'S FOR THAT
REASON ONLY THAT I WOULD I WOULD
ASK FOR A MOTION.
AND A SECOND THE MOVE THE BILL
AND WE CAN CONTINUE.
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
WE ARE UP AGAINST CERTAIN
DEADLINES.
THIS BILL IS DOUBLE REFERRED.
IN ORDER FOR YOU TO CONTINUE
EIGHT NET NEUTRALITY
CONVERSATION.
THAT LEADS CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST WHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE.
IT'S TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION.
RATHER THAN TO BECOME A MARTYR.
WITH NO BILL.
SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK IF
THERE WAS THE FIRST IN A SECOND
YOU CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AFTER THIS AND WE
COULD DEBATE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU KNOW.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
BEING A MARTYR.
THIS IS ABOUT.
ACTUALLY PROTECTING NET
NEUTRALITY I AND I WILL SAY I'M
DISAPPOINTED AS WELL.
I REVIEW IT YOU AND I HAVE HAD
NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS AND I CONSIDER
YOUR FRIENDS AND WE OF WORK AND
WE ARE FRIENDS AND WE'RE WORKING
ON THREE OR FOUR OTHER ISSUES
TOGETHER AND I AND AND WE ARE.
WE ARE WORKING ON HOMELESSNESS
HOUSING AND WILL CONTINUE AND
EVERY OTHER ISSUE I THINK WE
AGREE.
ON BUT THE REALITY IS AYE THAT
WE DID INDICATE A WILLINGNESS TO
TO GIVE ON SOME AREAS OF THE
BILL AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
AMENDMENTS THAT CAME FORWARD.
ARE REMOVE KEY PROTECTIONS THAT
WILL ALLOW THE ICE PEEVES TO
ENGAGE AND THEN THAT IS HOW YOU
VIOLATIONS THAT THEY HAVE
ENGAGED IN THE PAST AND SO.
I INDICATED THE BEGINNING THAT
WE COULDN'T ACCEPT APPOINTED
THAT THE COMMITTEE CHOSE EVEN
BEFORE HEARING THE BILL. TO
ABOUT THOSE AMENDMENTS I I'VE
I'VE BEEN YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
HERE AS LONG AS SOME MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE I'VE NEVER SEEN
THAT BEFORE I GUESS TALKING
BEFORE.
IT SEEMS ARE REALLY IRREGULAR TO
ME FOR A COMMITTED TO THAT BUT
I'VE.
I'VE SAID MY PIECE WE'VE ALWAYS
COMPLEX AMONG THIS BILL --
IDEA I GAVE UP PARTS OF THE BILL
AND SENATE ENERGY --
I UNDERSTAND THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS IS GIVEN TAKE.
BUT THE AMENDMENTS AT THIS
COMMITTEE.
IMPOSED THAT WERE ISSUED LAST
NIGHT AND THAT WERE IMPOSED
BEFORE HEARING TODAY ARE EXTREME
AMENDMENTS AND GOT THE BILL AND
THAT'S WHY COULDN'T.
SO INCIDENT BE SENATOR I ITEM.
I WANTED TO READ SOME POINTS IT
CAME IN AT THE LAST OUR FROM
SOME OF OUR RURAL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
REGARDING THE CONCERNS OF THE
BILL A HANDFUL OF FOLK BOTH
SUPPORTING THE BILL AS YOU
PRESENTED FROM MY DISTRICT AND A
HANDFUL OF FOLKS OPPOSING IT.
AS PRESENTED I'D I I DID WANT TO
TO READ SOME OF THAT TO YOU
GIVEN OPPORTUNITY THAT'S THE
QUESTION.
I'M LOOK I I AM INTERESTED IN
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT.
YOU MAY NO LONGER WANT TO CARRY
THIS BILL --
I'D BE HAPPY TO AND I DON'T KNOW
THEIR THE COLLEAGUES ON THIS
BIAS THAT WOULD JOIN ME IN
TAKING THE LEAD ON THIS ISSUE --
TO FURTHER THE CONVERSE BECAUSE
I THINK LIKE THE CHAIRMAN HAS
STATED THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE.
A NET NEUTRALITY --
DEBATE AND DISCUSSION ARE
CONTINUING TO MOVE IN THE
PROCESS AND SO I'D MAKE.
A MOTION TO AMEND THE BILL AND
AS AS AMENDED --
TO MOVE THE CONVERSATION FORWARD
MY HOPE WOULD BE THAT IT'S WITH
YOU -- AND
NOT --
WITHOUT RIGHT BUT I'M WILLING --
TO DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE PUT
MY NAME ON THE BILL AND CARRY
FORWARD THE CONVERSATION --
AS IT.
BEGINS HERE --
WE HAVE A SECOND THAT MOTION.
THOUGHT WHAT'S THE MOTION.
SO MY MOTION WOULD BE --
TO MOVE THE BILL AS AMENDED AND
I KNOW YOU --
FOR YOU'VE SAID YOU DON'T WANT
TO MOVE THIS CONVERSATION
FORWARD I'M MORE THAN WILLING --
TO AT CARRY THE CONVERSATION
FROM THIS POINT FORWARD WITH YOU
I HOPE OR OR HOW OR WITHOUT THAT
HAVE BECAUSE I THINK THERE NEEDS
TO BE A NET NEUTRALITY.
DEBATE AND DISCUSSION CONTINUING
TO MOVE I'M NOT GONNA GO.
YET THE QUESTION IT BUT YES IN.
I'LL LET YOU RESPOND TO THAT BUT
IT'S ALSO UNFAIR FOR ME TO GO
BACK.
AND TELL COMMITTEE RIGHT BEFORE
A COMMITTEE HEARING HEY LOOK AT
ALL THE ALL THE BACK AND FORTH
AND MAKE A DECISION RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S ON OUR
SIDE.
IT'S ON IT WOULD BE UNFAIR FOR
ME TO WALK A PIECE OF PAPER OVER
YOU RIGHT NOW AND SAY.
MAKE A DECISION.
IT'S UNFAIR FOR ME TO NOW TO
COME BACK TOWARD COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS POINT IN AND SAY
AND MAKE A DECISION ON THIS.
YOU MAY VIEW THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
THROUGH YOUR LANDS THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ARE SIMPLY. TO MOVE A
CONVERSATION.
FOR AND TO AND TO HAVE.
STRONG NET NEUTRALITY BILL.
YOU MAY YOU MAY ANSWER HIS
QUESTION I WOULD PREFER NOT TO
GO THROUGH WITH THAT FOUGHT BACK
AND FORTH DEBATE FOR THE DECORUM
OF THE HOUSE.
A BIT YOU CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT IF YOU MIGHT
RESTATE YOUR QUESTION MISTER
GARCIA DOWN THE QUESTION SO MY
FIRST.
THE HARMONIES THAT I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL [inaudible]
AS AMENDED.
I WOULD ALSO.
PUT ON THE TABLE WRITE THAT DOWN.
IF YOU NO LONGER WANT TO MOVE
THIS CONVERSATION FORWARD AS THE
PRINCIPAL AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
AND I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO PUT
MY NAME ON THE BILL.
AND WE HOPE THAT THERE ARE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT
ARE INTERESTED IN CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION AS WELL.
SO THAT KIND OF A SITE.
POINT THAT I'M MAKING AN AND I
DID WANT TO JUST READ OFF SOME
OF THE LETTERS THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED FROM.
RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE
MARDIN'S EFFORTS QUESTION YES
YES NO THAT ARE OBVIOUSLY I'VE
INDICATED WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
HOP AND THE COMMITTEE WILL DO
IT'S GOING TO DO --
I'M ALWAYS ONE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS I'M YOU KNOW I AS
YOU AND I HAVE HAD OF LIVE UP
WITH MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
SO I'M NOT ONE THAT SAYS YOU
KNOW DISAPPEAR ALL WE WILL
ALWAYS HAVE CONVERSATIONS --
SO THAT DOTSON NEVER GOING TO BE
AN ISSUE --
BUT I'M SORRY THAT.
BUT MR LOW HER QUESTION
[inaudible]
THE COMMENT.
YOU KNOW IF.
THEY THINK YOU VERY MUCH MS
CHAIR -- I
WOULD JUST A SECOND THIS MOTION
BECAUSE WHAT I'VE SEEN HERE IS
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHICH IS
THAT.
I OFTENTIMES WHEN THERE IS A
CONVERSATION WITH RESPECT TO
POLICY IT APPEARS THAT.
YOU HAVE BOTH SIDES IN IN IN
UNIFORM AND IN UNISON AND
OPPOSITION. TO THE MUST BE A
SWEET SPOT. TO WHAT WE SEE HERE
BEFORE US [inaudible]
AND MY APOLOGIES I WAS
PRESENTING IN SENATE ANY
GOVERNMENT FINANCE BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IF THIS
BILL DOES NOT MOVE FORWARD AS IS
TODAY THAT WITH THEIR IS NO NET
NEUTRALITY BILL.
MOVING FORWARD IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE MISTER.
CORRECT --
DELEON DID NOT PRESENT HIS BILL
AND I CANNOT SPEAK FOR HIM
WHETHER HE WOULD CONTINUE OR NOT
CONTINUE SURE SO IT HAVING SAID
THAT GIVEN THE ABSENCE OF ANY
VEHICLE MOVING FORWARD WITH
RESPECT IN NET NEUTRALITY.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE OF THE
CITY STATE OF CALIFORNIA TAKE A
POSITION --
IN THIS FRAMEWORK AND WE'VE
HEARD TESTIMONY ON BOTH SIDES --
ABOUT THE POLICY RAMIFICATIONS
OF INTERSTATE.
I WAS OF THE AYE I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE I THINK IT'S OUR
OBLIGATION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE A STRONG
POSITION IN THIS FRAMEWORK.
I UNDERSTAND THE SENATOR WINNER
YOUR PASSION ON THIS ISSUE BUT I
WOULD IMPLORE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD.
GIVEN THAT THIS IS JUST THE
FIRST COMMITTEE MOVING FORWARD
AND THAT THEY'RE STILL ALLOWS
FOR ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS AS
TIMES MOVE FORWARD. TO ALLOW FOR
THAT CONVERSATION AND DIALOGUE
TO OCCUR SO I ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS BECAUSE ABSENCE THE
VEHICLE THAT PRET THE BILL THAT
YOU HAVE BEFORE US THERE WILL BE
NO NET NEUTRALITY BILL. FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS TO%
CONSIDER IN THE GREATLY DESIRE
AND I KNOW THAT MANY OF US IN
ARKANSAS.
HE'S ALSO WANT TO SEE THE SAME
THING.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE ALL WANT --
A STRONG THAT NEUTRALITY BILL TO
MOVE FOR THAT ACTUALLY PROTECTS
MENTALITY AND AS WE RECEIVED OUR
YOU KNOW IN OUR LETTER FROM.
LEADER PELOSI AND ALSO FROM
CONGRESSWOMAN AS TO FROM YOUR
NECK OF THE WOODS ARE OR NEARBY
AT LEAST ON THAT THEY ARE.
DOING THIS BILL INCLUDING THE
SPECIFIC PROTECTIONS OF THE OF
COMMITTEE REMOVED IS VERY
IMPORTANT --
I ALSO I JUST WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT CHAIRMAN AND I HAD WE'VE
HAD EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS OVER
THE LAST.
A NUMBER OF WEEKS I AND WHEN --
THE CHAIR SHARED WITH US OF THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS OUR LAST
NIGHT.
NO WE SPENT HOURS YOU KNOW
QUICKLY GOING THROUGH AND SAYING
WE CAN AGREE TO THIS WE CAN
AGREE TO THAT WE CAN AGREE TO
THIS WE CAN'T READ ABOUT SO WE
HAVE.
ABSOLUTELY BEEN WILLING TO HAVE
THAT BACK AND FORTH I ALWAYS DO
THAT ON AS HAVE WE YET --
ADD AND BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
THEY COMMITTEE YOU KNOW
AMENDMENTS WERE AS PROPOSED AND
AND THAT'S SORT OF WHERE WE ARE
BUT WERE.
YOU KNOW CONVERSATION IS ALWAYS
A GOOD THING --
BUT I I BY SO TO MAKE CLEAR MY
POSITION ON WHAT HAPPENS IF I
MISS HIM AT MIDNIGHT ONE FINAL
COME IT'S IT'S JUST AGAIN AS AN
ARENA AYE.
AS AND OFTENTIMES WE WE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE DON'T DEAL IN
ABSOLUTES AND WHAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US NOW.
IS EITHER AT IF YOU WITHDRAW
YOUR BILL THERE IS NOTHING.
BUT AT LEAST MOVING FORWARD WITH
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE
SOMETHING TO LEASE CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION.
IN THE NEXT POLICY COMMITTEES
AND ALSO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND SO I JUST I'M GLAD MY LAST
COMES IS JUST OUT OF EMPLOYER
YOU TO HELP.
TO TECHNOLOGIES THAT THAT THEY
IMPORTANCE OF AND I WITH WITH
ONLY A FEW EXCEPTION ISSUES.
LIKE -- PER
INTO OUR COMMUNITY OR TWO
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE ETCETERA
I IDEAL IN VERY FEW ABSOLUTES
YOU CAN ALWAYS.
OF WORK OUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
WORK I'VE DONE --
AND THE BILLS I PASSED --
WE'VE NEGOTIATED ON MANY MANY
MANY BILLS AND I DON'T HAVE TAKE
A PURIST POSITION AND SO THIS IS
NOT ABOUT I'M NOT TAKING A
PURIST POSITION A TWENTY TWO WE
MADE CHANGES.
WE'VE INDICATED A WILLINGNESS TO
MAKE MORE CHANGES --
BUT THESE AMENDMENTS GO FAR SO
THAT THAT'S THAT'S ALL THIS IS
NOT ABOUT BEING A PURIST BECAUSE
THAT REALLY WORKS.
BUT MR SHIPP AYE I THINK I'D BUY
A HAVE A DUTY HERE TOO TUBES
BREED WITH YOUR PERMISSION SOME
OF THE RURAL CONSTITUENTS THAT
OF IMPARTED OUR OFFICE OVER THE
LAST TO BE TWO HOURS AND IT WITH
PERMISSION CHAIRMAN OF REACH AND
THINGS OF RESPOND.
TO QUESTION AS A IS A COMPLETE
IS A CENTER OF US GOT WIENER
FROM SAN FRANCISCO DOES NOT
APPEAR TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
MEANS TO LIVE AND WORK IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA WITH NO INTERNET
ACCESS -- NO
EMAIL WILL STREAMING NO GPS NO
ONLINE ACCESS TO JOBS COMMERCE
HEALTH CARE PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICES EDUCATION AND AND THE
WORLD.
THE GENERAL RIGHTS --
THESE HAVE JUST THE SENATOR SAYS
HE WANTS TO PROTECT FOR
EVERYBODY BUT IN MANY PARTS OF
RURAL CALIFORNIA WE STILL HAVE
NO INTERNET ACCESS [inaudible]
PROTECT.
IT SAYS ARE YOU KNOW GET TO THE
SAP. FOR RURAL CALIFORNIA IT
WOULD ADD TO THE ALREADY HIGH
COST TO PROVIDE INTERNET ACCESS
WERE COST TO BUILD AND MAINTAIN
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE EXPONENTIALLY
HIGHER.
THAN IN URBAN AREAS LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT NETWORK
OPERATIONS A REMOTE ROUGH
TERRAIN ARE MORE COMPLEX AND THE
COST ADDRESSED THE NEW NORMAL
FIRE DANGER.
LARGELY IN ROW AREAS INCREASE
EACH DAY --
MOREOVER SP EIGHT POINT TWO WILL
HARM CONSUMERS WILL ALREADY HAVE
ACCESS BY TAKING AWAY POPULAR
FREE DATA SERVICE PLANS THE MAKE
STREAMING ANOTHER DEALER USES
AFFORDABLE. FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS --
WITHOUT FREE DATA PLANS CUSTOMER
BILLS COULD RISE BY AS MUCH AS
THIRTY DOLLARS A MONTH.
WE SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD IT AND
THOSE ARE OF STATEMENTS FROM A
ORGANIZATIONS BOTH FOR MORE
MUSICIANS WILL BE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE.
ARE AND OTHER RULE ORGANIZATIONS
IN OUR DISTRICT THESE ARE SOME
OF THE LETTERS THAT CAME IN OVER
THE LAST IN TWO HOURS AYE I
THINK IT IT IT DEV MERITS YOU
KNOW AN OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO
RESPOND.
I APPRECIATE THAT OPPORTUNITY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON AND AS YOU
KNOW LAST YEAR I FLORA TERMS OF
YOUR BILL THAT YOU DID WITH ON
THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER AYE WE ARE CURRY IN AND
OUT AND OTHERS OF YOU BIPARTISAN
BILL TO TRY TO WITH THE TNC TO
TRY TO EXPAND RURAL INTERNET
ACCESS DIED IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE SO MANY.
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL ON HOW
THAT ACCESS --
IS UNACCEPTABLE I'VE THIS BILL
IS NOT GOING TO MAKE IT HARDER
FOR THEM TO GET THAT ACCESS WHAT
IT DOES MEAN FOR RURAL
CALIFORNIA AS YOU KNOW.
DIED THE MORE RURAL YOU GET THE
MORE LIKELY IT IS THAT YOU HAVE.
ONE INTERNET OPTION.
I I HAVE FRIENDS WHO LIVE EVEN
ENOUGH UNINCORPORATED PART OF
CINEMA COUNTY WHICH I I WOULD I
WOULD NOT CONSIDER TO BE CLASSIC
WORLD IT'S STILL IN A VERY OR
CLOSE TO ORGANIZE THEIR AND THEY
ONLY HAVE ONE OPTION.
AND I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WE'RE
GETTING OUT INTO THE MORE AND
MORE RURAL AREAS ONE OPTION AND
WHEN YOU HAVE ONE OPTION AND THE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER HAS
THE POWER WITHOUT ANY TRILOGY TO
SAY.
YOU CAN GO HERE BUT YOU CAN'T GO
THERE THAT DOTSON EVEN BIGGER
PROBLEM NO TOADIES IN A BIGGER
PROBLEM WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE.
A COMPETITION NAM I DO JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT THIS WHOLE ISSUE
ABOUT HIGHER COSTS AND HARMING
CONSUMERS OF FREE DATA AND I AM
NOT IN ANYWAY COMMENTING ON THE
BIG THE PEOPLE OR GROUPS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH YOU I KNOWN.
NOTHING ABOUT WHERE THEY CAME
FROM OR WHAT IF.
HEARING --
THIS HAPPENING ON THE ICE PIECE
HAVE BEEN --
FUNDING BILL VERY WELL FUNDED
CAMPAIGN IN THE WEEKS LEADING UP
TO THIS HEARING I KNOW I EACH OF
YOU HAS BEEN TARGETED WITH
TWITTER ADS AND FACEBOOK GUIDES.
FROM A GROUP CALLED CAL
INNOVATES Y. WHICH IS FUNDED BY
A TNT.
ARE SAYING THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HARM CONSUMERS THIS IS TERRIBLE.
JOHN AND I WOULD ALSO HAD A
SENIOR CITIZENS WHO WERE BEING
USED EITHER WROBEL CALLED HER
PHONE BANKS --
SAYING --
YOUR BILLS ARE GONNA GO UP.
YOUR BILLS ARE GONNA GO OUT
WHICH IS FALSE.
I AND IN TERMS OF THESE FREE
DATA PLANS ARE THE FREE DATA
PLANS CALLED ZERO RATING --
WHICH I HOPE IT'S ALSO IT'S
CORPORATE SELF DEALING IT'S
BASICALLY --
COMCAST OR AT INTO YOUR VERIZON
SAYING IF YOU USE MY SERVICE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO PAY.
A DOZEN COUNTING INSERTED A COP
IF YOU USE MY COMPETITORS
SERVICE ACCOUNTS AGAINST YOU DID
A COP IT'S A WAY OF PUSHING
PEOPLE TO FAVORITE SERVICES.
AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU HAVE
THESE PREDICT FUNDS ARE NOT
TRULY FREE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT. ZERO
RATING ONLY HAS VALUE IF YOU
KEEP THE DATA CAP LOW.
IF YOU HIGH DATA COPS IF YOU
UNLIMITED DATA PLANS THAT ARE
AFFORDABLE PEOPLE NO ONE NEEDS
PREDATE APPLIANCES YOU HAVE ALL
THE DATA YOU NEED.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS IN COUNTRIES
THAT HAVE RESTRICTED OFF THESE
ARE ZERO RATING PLANS.
DATA CAPS OF GOING UP UNLIMITED
DATA PLANS HAVE BECOME CHEAPER
AND CONSUMERS GET TO DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES.
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE LOW DATA
COPS AND ZERO RATING --
DAN DE A PARTICULAR FOR LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS YOU IF I IF YOU
IF I CAN AFFORD UNLIMITED A PLAN
I CAN GO WHEREVER I WANT.
IF I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF MONEY I
HAVE TO PAY CAP AND THEY TELL ME.
YOU CAN USE THESE PRODUCTS BUT
NOT OTHERS AND WE HAVE ON THE
WESTERN CENTER FOR LAW AND
POVERTY COLORS OF CHANGES CENTER
FOR MEDIA AYE JUSTICE OUR WIDE
ARRAY OF GROUPS THAT ADVOCATE
FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE PER
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THAT HAD BEEN CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT
ZERO RATING HARMS LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS --
SO YOU KNOW THAT DIED IS SO DO I
THINK THE REALITY OF WHERE WE
ARE BUT I I DO RESPECT OTHERS
USE OF YOUR CONCERTS I THINK FOR
THOSE REASONS RIGHT THAT THAT
YOU'VE JUST.
RESPONDED AND FOR THOSE THAT I
STATED FROM OXYGEN SO THIS
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO CONTINUE
[inaudible]
WE WE HAVE A FIRST WHAT IS IT
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A FIRST AND SECOND TO
PASS THE BILL AS AMENDED --
THE CHAIRS RECCO IS AN AYE
BECAUSE WE NEED TO KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION GOING.
I APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK INTO
MASS CITY.
ON THIS ISSUE --
DEBORAH CHAIRS ROCCO IS AN AYE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS DUE PROCESS AMENDED TO
COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE HOLDEN
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW AYE AYE LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOTEPAD SIN.
PERSON NOT VOTING [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
THE MEASURE IS ON CALL.
WE'RE GIVEN A FEW MINUTES FOR
THE OF ROOM. TO CLEAR OUT AND IT
WILL CONTINUE TO BUSINESS
.
WE'D LIKE TO NOW CONTINUE THE
MEETING -- A
MISTER HILL IS HERE I DON'T WANT
TO MAKE THEM WAIT ANY LONGER --
WE'D LIKE TO START AN SP.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF ONE OF THE WITNESSES
HAS TO GO WITH ME WE TO FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR FIRST THAT WORK YOU
MAY I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
AND I AM YOUR SALVATION I'VE TO
EASY BILLS FOR YOU TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO ASK EVERYONE WHO'S
HERE -- TO
BRING THE NOISE LEVEL DOWN I
LIKE TO BE COURTEOUS TO MISTER
HILL WHO'S PRESENTING.
I APOLOGIZE MISTER HILL FOR
DIRECTING YOU.
THAT'S WHY MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU I'M GONNA ASK ONE MORE TIME
THAT WE BE COURTEOUS TO THE
SENATOR WHO'S PRESENTING.
I APOLOGIZE A ONE MORE TIME
ISRAEL.
THANK YOU MINIATURE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HELP IN AND LEADERSHIP
IN IN AND YOUR STAFFS IN THIS --
IN THIS LEGISLATION.
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
ALLOWS THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO BETTER ENFORCE
AGAINST UNLICENSED
TRANSPORTATION CARRIERS.
BY ALLOWING THE P. YOU SEE TO
IMPOUND VEHICLES UNDER THEIR
JURISDICTION A NUMBER OF AUDITS
OF P. UC'S TRANSPORTATION
ENFORCEMENT BUREAU OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS SEVEN BECAUSE
CONCLUDED.
THAT THE QUOTE BRANCH DOES NOT.
IMPLY WITH STATE LAW MOST
COMMONLY ILLEGAL VEHICLES
OPERATE WITHOUT PVC LICENSES
UNDERCUTTING BOTH LAWFUL
CARRIERS OF THEIR BUSINESS.
AND THE P. YOU SEE A PROPER
SAFETY MONITORING OF THESE
VEHICLES A P. UC'S FISCAL OFFICE
HAS NOTED THEY CURRENTLY HAVE
ALMOST EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS WORTH OF UNPAID FINES
FROM UNLICENSED CARRIERS.
BECAUSE THESE CARRIERS REALIZE
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
ENFORCEMENT A AFTER THE P. YOU
SEE ISSUES A CITATION COLLEAGUES
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
CLOSES ONE REMAINING
RECOMMENDATION.
CALLED FOR IN THE LAST P. UC
TRANSPORTATION BRANCH AUDIT THAT
IS TO ALLOW THE FEW CD IMPOUND
ROAD BROKE THE CARRIERS.
IVERS OF EVER WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
WHICH I HEAR MEMBERS GREAT COOK
RIVERS IN THE GRAVEL SECOND BUT
THANK YOU MOTION SAFE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS GRAY
COOKWARE WAS INTEGRATED
CALIFORNIA LIVERY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR ENFORCEMENT
FOR THE PC THANK YOU
[inaudible]
BUT ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES THIS IS AND HOW BIG A VERY
MUCH IT'S JUST A QUESTION WITH
RESPECT TO PARA TRANSIT IN THAT.
APPLICATION TO TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES.
AND THE ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF JOB OF
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE LIVES
THAT ISSUES OF THE I THINK THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO SB THIRTEEN
SALAS GETTING.
WE WE WENT OUT ORDER I APOLOGIZE.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AYE PERFECT
YASSER RIVAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
AGAIN.
MAN SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON S. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FULL.
WASHES DO PASTA PUBLIC SAFETY.
SANTIAGO AYE AYE SANTIAGO AYE.
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW AYE LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
MATHIS PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
RODRIGUEZ.
HE MEASURES ON CALL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
BUT I'M GOING TO PRESENT
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX I AM SURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SIX INSURERS
CALIFORNIA'S DISABLED CITIZENS.
HAVE ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES SERVICES WHERE
NO THE TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION
ALMOST ALWAYS BENEFITS THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
THIS HAS BEEN TRUE OF THE TNC IS
WHICH HAVE MADE PROGRESS IN
PROVIDING ACCESS TO DEAF AND
BLIND PERSONS AS WELL AS ELDERLY.
NEEDING EXTRA ASSISTANCE BUT
WHEELCHAIR USERS ESPECIALLY NOT
UNFOLDING MOTORIZED WHEELCHAIR
USERS HAVE NOTED A CLEAR LACK OF
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES OF TNC
PROVIDERS.
MANY LOCALITIES LIKE SEATTLE AND
CHICAGO HAVE ADDRESS THIS
DISPARITY BY ASSESSING THE
SURCHARGE ON TNC USED TO HELP
PAY FOR ACCESSIBLE TRANSIT
OPTIONS.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
FEW STATES TO REGULATE TNC IS
STATEWIDE THAT'S THE SOLUTION TO
TNC DISABILITY ACCESS
UNAVAILABILITY IN CALIFORNIA
WILL REQUIRE STATEWIDE
COORDINATION.
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX
MANDATES THE P. YOU SEE DEVELOP
REGULATIONS FOR TNC
ACCESSIBILITY FOR PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES INCLUDING SS IN A
FEE ON TNC USED TO FUND.
ON DEMAND WHEELCHAIR ACCESSIBLE
SERVICES COLLEGE DISABILITY
ACCESS.
TO THE DNC'S SHOULD BE OF THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY I HAVE
WITNESSES AT SPEAKING SUPPORT
WHICH CHAIR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND MY UP THE UPPER
CHIN DUE TO SPEAK.
I'M JOINT EFFORT WILL BE WAS A
SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR'S OFFICE AND
DISABILITY WHICH IS ACTUALLY
EASY ABA COMPLIANCE OFFICE. FOR
THIS CD OF SET AT SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX BECAUSE
IT WILL CREATE A SELF FUNDED
PROGRAM IN A MECHANISM TO ENSURE
THAT ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DISABILITY COMMUNITY --
HAVE ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS ON DEMAND --
THAT ARE NOT LONGER AVAILABLE TO
FOLKS USING NON FOLDING MOBILITY
DEVICES SUCH AN ELECTRIC
WHEELCHAIR SCOOTERS.
WHEN I FIRST COME WHEN I CAME TO
SACRAMENTO JUST THIS MORNING?
I HAD TO WALK ALL THE WAY
[inaudible]
CHEN -- EVEN
THOUGH THE WHERE EITHER.
YOU KNOW --
ACCESSIBLE --
BY SAYS --
BAD DIGITAL TIMING I DID NOT
HAVE THE OPTION TO TAP MY APP
AND BE ABLE TO GET HERE IN
RECORD TIME.
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT I WOULD
LIKE TO REMIND YOU OF THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
NEARLY TWENTY EIGHT YEARS AGO
WAS STILL ALLOW A CLASS OF
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED OF EQUAL UNEQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL PARTICIPATION IN ACCESS
TO SERVICES OF THIS SAME QUALITY
AND AVAILABILITY HAS THE GENERAL
POPULATION?
NO MORE SEPARATE BUT EQUAL.
I'M TRANSPORTATION IMMOBILITY
AND OF PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE TO
WHAT'S MEETINGS THAT AND AND
IT'S THE WAY WEEKLY BARRACKS
WERE ABLE. TO THRIVE IN OUR
LIVES. FOR MANY OF THE HAS OF
THE EXISTING THE EXISTING
WHEELCHAIR ACCESSIBLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS ARE NOT
ADEQUATE AND THEY'RE CERTAINLY
NOT EQUIVALENT ESPECIALLY IN
AREAS WHERE THE GOOD PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK.
DOESN'T WORK SPEAKING FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE NOW I'M
GONNA TELL A SHARE MY PERSONAL
STORY.
I'M IN THE EXPERIENCE OF ALSO
HAD THEIR WHEELCHAIR USERS --
WHICH NO UNFOLDED.
NON FOLDABLE WHEELCHAIRS IN OUR
SUITS AND MANY OF US AND WORKING
PROFESSIONALS WE FREQUENTLY
EXTEND WORK MEETINGS ON
SCHEDULES PROTECT ENTERED OUT
WHAT ACCESS TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
FOREVER ACCEPTABLE TRANSPORT A
IS NOT AVAILABLE OR VIABLE --
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
INTENTION BEING THURMOND WHETHER
IMAGINE HAVING TO WAIT AT THE
BUS STOP BECAUSE YOU'RE ONLY ADD
TO YOUR ONLY OPTION.
IS TO ACTUALLY TAKE A BUS THAT
TAKES QUITE A LONG TIME AND
YOU'RE SITTING THERE IN THE
RIGHT --
STILL AS A RESULT --
AS A RESULT --
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT IS THAT
LAWSUIT IF THERE IS A COST OF
TIME?
PRODUCTIVITY MISSED OPPORTUNITY
PERSON MUST STAMINA.
HEALTH AND ALSO SOME GAMES
REPUTATIONS AS PROFESSIONALS AND
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE OUR NON
DISABLED COLLEAGUES OR DOESN'T
DOESN'T LAST --
WHAT NOT USING A NON FOLDABLE
CRACKS DOWN WORK AT TEN A
WORKING LUNCH AND THEN COME BACK --
TO THEIR MEETING --
WELL WOULD TRADE --
TO HAIL A RAMPED VEHICLE USING
THE TNC OUT.
OF THERE ARE NO WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBLE VEHICLES ARE GONNA
EVER AVAILABLE ON WEEKENDS CLOSE
DESCENDS SO THERE IS NO
SATURATION OR AVAILABILITY OF OF
THE SERVICE.
AS A HOUSE SO I AM A MOTHER AND
THE MOTHER OF TWO YOUNG CHILDREN
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN ONE OF THEM
WAS SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN TIMES WHEN I
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO GET TO THEM
QUICKLY.
OUT BECAUSE OF A SCHOOL
EMERGENCY OR ELEMENTS AND
FRANKLY THAT IS ONE OF THE TIMES
I AM THAT I AM.
MOSTLY ANGERED --
AND FRUSTRATED.
I'M EITHER LOVE LAST MYSELF
INCLUDED.
POPPED OUT OF SOCIAL ACTIVITIES
ESPECIALLY IN THE EVENINGS AFTER
DARK EITHER BECAUSE PUBLIC
TRANSPORT HE'S NOT AVAILABLE --
LAWYER BECAUSE THEY OF SAFETY
ISSUES.
MANY OF US IN THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY SAID TO MYSELF COVER
LEARN TO COMPENSATE ARE FOR THIS
DAILY CHALLENGES AND PRE PLANNED
AND THE AMOUNT OF PRE PLANNING.
THAT GOES ON REALLY CREATES.
A SENSUAL MENTAL HEALTH HAZARDS.
THE POINT IS THAT NO INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD HAVE TO DO THIS SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THE WAY WE EMULATE.
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX IS
THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS WE SEE
STATEWIDE. TO ADDRESS THIS IN
EQUITY.
IN CALIFORNIA --
BY PROVIDING A VERY SPECIFIC
FUNDING MECHANISM AND SOLUTIONS
I AND MOST IMPORTANTLY A MANDATE
FOR COMPLETE AND TIMELY RESULTS.
I'M AND I KNOW THAT HAVE BROUGHT
US BACK TO THE EIGHT THE A ON
THE BED REALLY THIS IS WHAT WHAT
I'M GONNA HAVE TO MAYBE CUT THAT
DOWN AND GOES CONTINUE TO THE
NEXT ON WITNESSES AND BE BRIEF
ABOUT IT I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT.
EXTRA TIME BECAUSE IT WAS
UNSETTLED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THINK.
GOOD MORNING JOHN ROSS ON BEHALF
OF LEFT --
WE OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT THE GOALS
OF THIS BILL AND WE SUPPORT THE
BILL MOVING AT A COMMITTEE TODAY
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE CENTER STAFF.
HAD COUPLE MECHANICAL ISSUES
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO SORT OUT I
THINK WE'VE GOT CONCEPTUAL
AGREEMENT ON THAT NOTHING --
EARTHSHAKING BUT I APPRECIATE
THE SENATOR'S WILLINGNESS TO
KEEP WORKING WITH US TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THE SOME POSITION
THAT IT WORKS CORRECTLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
GOOD MORNING AUSTIN A WITH WITH
UBER -- WILL
ALSO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF OUR
COUNTERPARTS HERE SPIN OUT
FANTASTIC WORK ON THE CENTERS
OFFICE AND I THINK WE'VE GOT A
PACKAGE OF AMENDMENTS THAT IS --
WORK WELL FOR US AND WE'RE WE'RE
HOPEFUL TO SEE THOSE YOU KNOW
CARRIED OUT AFTER UP WITH TO THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS --
I'LL BE BRIEF BUT JUST TO GIVE A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON THE
ISSUE --
EXPANDING ACCESS TO WILL CHECKS
AS WELL VEHICLES THE CHALLENGE
THAT MANY CITIES AND STATES I'VE
STRUGGLE WITH STRUGGLE ADDRESS
FOR DECADES AS TRANSLATION
PROVIDERS.
THAT USE ONDEMAND RIGHT TRAPS
LIKE YOU WERE AT BECOME MORE
UBIQUITOUS THE SAME CHALLENGES
REMAIN HAS BEEN NOTED BY --
THAT WHEN THIS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO --
WE TAKE ACCESSIBILITY SERIOUSLY
AND ACOSTA WORKING UNABLE TO
INCREASE OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THIS IS INCLUDED.
IMPLEMENTING TACKLING VOICEOVER
AND TALK BACK.
TO DRIVERS OR DEATH.
WE ALSO PILOTING WITH PROGRAMS
IN CITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
OF MONEY POLICIES RUN
NONDISCRIMINATION ACCESSIBILITY.
UBER WAVE OPTION ENABLES WRITERS
WHO USE NON FOLDING MOTORIZED
WHEELCHAIRS TO REQUEST A RIDE
FOR DRIVERS IN WAVES THAT ARE
EQUIPPED WITH RAMPS ARE LAUGHS.
AND ALL DRIVERS ARE PARTNERING
WITH UBER AGREED TO TRANSPORT
WRITERS TO TRACK WHO TRAVEL WITH
SERVICE ANIMALS THEY'RE ALSO
EXPECTED TO ACCOMMODATE FOLDING
WHEELCHAIRS WALKERS ANOTHER
SYSTEM DEVICES. TO THE MAXIMUM
EXTENT FEASIBLE.
REGARDING SPECIALLY EQUIPPED
WAVES THE OBSTACLE HERE WITH
THIS ISSUE IS THAT --
UBER LEFT CANNOT OWN VEHICLES
USED BY DRIVERS AND DRIVERS
INDIVIDUALLY DETERMINE WHEN
WHERE AND HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
DRIVE.
AS A RESULT WE NEED TO FIND
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS --
TO ENSURE THE AVAILABILITY OF
THESE VEHICLES AND ACCESS THE
WILL OF THE TO THOSE WAVES FOR
DRIVERS WHO. WON PROVIDE RIDES
INTO PERHAPS.
I WOULD SECOND.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES OF
SUPPORT YET THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN ROBINSON WAS SHOT HERE
IT'S WE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRADES ASSOCIATION.
THE SAN FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AS WELL AS
A SENATOR COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT ON SUPPORT AND THANK
THE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR EFFORTS
WORKING WITH US.
HIS NAME AND POSITION PLEASE.
IT WAS YOUR CHARACTER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WERE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS --
LEGISLATION PRIMARILY BECAUSE IT
DOES RECOGNIZE THE ONGOING
ACCESSIBILITY REQUIREMENTS AT
THE SAME TIME OF TRYING TO
IMPROVE --
THE ACCESSIBILITY THANK YOU.
HAIFA CHRISTIAN MCMAHON WITH THE
ARE CAN UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AFTERNOON HENRIK INSURANCE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS WE
ARE SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A LOT APOLOGIZE LASSEN SUPPORT
THIS IS BERMAN LOAN FROM CENTER
FOR INDEPENDENT INDIVIDUALS TO
DISPEL THESE.
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION.
AND ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
DAVID YOU HAVE MISTER CHAIR JUST --
I AM IN VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
BILL AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR I JUST WANT TO MAKE A A
POINT OF OBSERVATION THAT EVER
EVEN WHEN I RECALL MY EXPERIENCE
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
WE WOULD HAVE PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED PARA TRANSIT --
AND TRANSFUSION SERVICES THAT.
EVEN WITH THAT OF PUBLIC SUBSIDY
WE HAD INADEQUATE SERVICES FOR
THAT THIS DISABILITY AND AND
DISABLED COMMUNITIES AND WITH
RESPECT TO TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES ARE RELATIVELY
NEWER.
A MODE OF TRANSPORTATION WE SEE
THE CHALLENGES THAT EXIST AND SO
I THINK A RECOGNIZING THAT
PATIENCE IS IMPORTANT BUT ALSO
UNDERSTANDING SOME OF THE
LIMITATIONS --
BUT YET WE MUST CONTINUE TO MOVE
TO ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE I
WOULD MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THINK THINK THE
COMMENTS OF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW AND AND HE'S ACTUALLY
CORRECT IN.
IN MY GOAL AND I THINK THE THE
GOAL OF THIS ENTIRE EFFORT IS IN
WHICH WE HAVE.
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION EVERYONE THAT THAT
AND THAT ARE PASSED TO MAKE IT
WORK AT THE END OF THE DAY WHICH
IS THE KEY WITH THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE VIA INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE.
THE EQUIPMENT IN PLACE TO MAKE
IT WORK BUT EVERYONE HAS TO BE --
IN AGREEMENT AND WE WILL BE
WORKING TO MAKE TO GET TO THAT
POINT I RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE
VOTE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
NAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX
MOTION IS TO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION.
SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE BONTA CERVANTES
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW AYE LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA
RODRIGUEZ.
BOB BALL THAT MICHELLE A FUTURE
THEY COMMIT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER --
YOU MAY PROCEED ON S. B..
TEN FOURTEEN THANK YOUR CHAIR
MEMBERS SP --
TEN FOURTEEN BEFORE I GET INTO
WHAT SIMPLE WE START MATT MASK
YOU IF YOU WOULD ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT'S WHAT
I WAS GONNA OPEN WITH I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT THAT'S IT ARTICULATED
ME ANALYSIS.
REMOVES THE HOW 2% GOAL --
SO NOW ALL GET INTO THE CONTENT
OF THE BILL --
IT.
TNC EASE OUR TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES OR MOST OF US
REFERRED IS RIDE HAILING
SERVICE'S ARE GREATLY CONVENIENT
AND MOST OF US UTILIZED THEM WE
IT'S BENEFICIAL FOR SO MANY
PURPOSES --
AND AS A RESULT MORE AND MORE
FOLKS ARE USING THEM WHICH IS A
GREAT THING AND WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES.
THAT.
WHERE A INCREASING NUMBER OF THE
VEHICLE MILES WITH?
THOSE COMMUNITIES ARE DUE TO BUY.
VEHICLES DEPLOYED BY OUR
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANIES
NO THIS IS AT THE SAME TIME
WHERE FOSSIL FUEL VEHICLES ARE
STILL THE NUMBER ONE SOURCE.
OF AIR POLLUTION EMISSIONS AND
GREENHOUSE GAS TAILPIPE
EMISSIONS.
AND OF COURSE CALIFORNIA PRIDES
ITSELF ON HAVING VERY STRONG
BOTH AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE
PROTECTION GOALS SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS BASICALLY.
ENGAGES OUR TNC COMPANIES AS
PARTNERS IN HELPING CALIFORNIA
MEET ARE VERY.
LEGITIMATE GOALS FOR BOTH AIR
QUALITY SO CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE
PROTECTION --
MISTER BILL HOLD FOR ONE SECOND
CERTAINLY WANT TO LIFT THE CALL
AND HE TO TO SORT.
I SB A TWO TO THE CHAIR WAS I S.
B. EIGHT TWO TWO MOTION IS
DEPOSITS AMENDED. TO COMMITTEE
ON PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION CERVANTES
[inaudible]
CERVANTES AYE.
MEASURES SOME CALL YOU MAY
CONTINUE I APOLOGIZE THANK YOU
CHAIR.
SO WHAT S. B. TEN FOURTEEN DOES
IS IT ESTABLISHES A CLEAN MILES
STANDARD.
AND AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
THAT WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE P. YOU SEE.
THE CPUC WHICH OBVIOUSLY HAS
ALREADY THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
REGULATE OUR TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES SO IT DOESN'T
ESTABLISH ANY NEW THE THE PEW
CRT HAS THAT AUTHORITY --
I'VE BEEN MEETING REGULARLY WITH
OUR TNC COMPANIES AND BASED ON
THOSE DISCUSSIONS HAVE TAKEN
SOME SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE PART TARGETS.
AND REPLACE.
WITH A PROCESS THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM IN OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENGAGE WITH THE PC AND SETTING
IN DETERMINING FAIR TARGETS BOTH
THE PC AND THE OUR AIR RESOURCES
BOARD -- NOW
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT'S RAISED
OCCASIONALLY IS THE FACT THAT
THE TNC STONE OWN VEHICLES.
AND THEY THE DRIVERS WHO UNIT
WHO ARE IN EFFECT I'D DEPLOYED
THROUGH THEIR PLATFORMS ARE NOT
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND SUCH ALL OF
THIS IS TRUE --
BUT WE ALREADY S. A STATE HAVE
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS WHERE WE
ARE SUPPORTING AND SUBSIDIZING
WHICH SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
MONEY TO SUPPORT CHARGING PUBLIC
CHARGING THROUGHOUT THE STATES
OR CHARGING OF VEHICLES THAT
THIS WOULD.
THIS BILL WOULD PROMOTE AND
ADDITIONALLY REBATES.
AND OUR REBATE PROGRAM INTO THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM.
SPECIFIES THAT 25% OF THAT
REBATE WOULD GO TO LOW INCOME
DRIVERS NOW INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH.
ARE -- WHILE
TEN FOURTEEN MY BILL DOES NOT
PUT THIS ONUS ON THE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANIES
TO ASSIST THE DRIVERS ON THEIR
PLATFORM.
UBER HAS JUST ANNOUNCED PILOTS
IN SACRAMENTO SAN FRANCISCO AND
SAN DIEGO WHERE THEY ARE GOING
TO PAY A DRIVERS.
OF ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES THAT
ARE DEPLOYED ON THEIR PLATFORM
ONE DOLLAR TWO DOLLARS FIFTY
MORE PER RIDE.
SO THAT'S A PILOT THAT THEY
THEMSELVES ARE ALREADY ENGAGED
IN.
I'M.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
PRODUCTIVELY WITH THE TNC
COMPANIES ON FURTHER AMENDMENTS
THAT WE MIGHT TAKE IN ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION SO WE MEET READ
REGULARLY WITH THEM.
BUT I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WILL
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD AND AS I
SAID GLADLY TAKING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I
WOULD LIKE MY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT TO NOW TESTIFIED.
I'M JUST WE COULD BE AMENDED
SHOULD BE TAKEN TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE S. AND WE WERE ALLOWED
TO MOVE THE BILL THE MOVE
FORWARD SIMPLY BECAUSE WE MISSED
DEADLINES IF WE DON'T
[inaudible]
YES.
BAG GOOD AFTERNOON --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS QUIBBLE
SOME HALF OF VALLEY CLEAN AIR
NOW WE ARE A NONPROFIT THAT
ADMINISTERS THE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAM --
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT SINCE
LAUNCHING THE PROGRAM IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE HAVE HELPED LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS LIVING IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
REPLACE OVER A THOUSAND OLDER
HIGH POLLUTING VEHICLES.
WITH MORE EFFICIENT OR ZERO
MISSION ONCE --
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL YOU KNOW
HELPS LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
ACCESS ELECTRIC VEHICLES --
BY PROVIDING UP TO NINETY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR --
STAY INCENTIVES FOR THEM TO
SCRAP THEIR OLDER CAR AND TO
PURCHASE A A CLEANER ALTERNATIVE
IN THE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT.
FUNDING THIS PROGRAM
CONSISTENTLY YEAR AFTER YEAR
GIVEN THE BENEFITS IT PROVIDES
TO LOW INCOME FOLKS.
AND GIVEN THE RISE OF POPULARITY
WITH TNC ISN'T THAT'S THE RISE
OF THE ENTITIES WE DO YOU REALLY
THINK THAT THERE IS A ROLE FOR
THIS INDUSTRY TO PLAY IN
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND HELPING US ACHIEVE
OUR AIR QUALITY IN CLIMATE GOALS --
THE CLEAN BECAUSE FOR ALL
PROGRAM REALLY IS AN EXISTING
TOOL AS A MISS SKINNER WAS
REFERRING --
TO THAT CAN HELP ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THE GOALS.
OF THIS BILL.
AND YOU KNOW THESE INCENTIVES
HAVE BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE AT
HELPING --
ATTRACTING LOW INCOME DRIVERS TO
EVE HE'S IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
WE THINK IT CAN BE M. A PRETTY
EFFECTIVE TOOL ACTUALLY HELPING.
LOOK MORE LOW INCOME DRIVERS
REPLACE OLDER VEHICLES THAT
DON'T NECESSARILY QUALIFY FOR
USE -- ON
THE TNC PLATFORM AND DOES GIVE
THEM A VEHICLE THAT WILL QUALIFY
AND GIVE MORE LIT LOW INCOME
FOLKS BETTER ACCESS --
TO IN OF DRIVING FOR SO
PRACTICALLY SPEAKING WE THINK
THE TOOLS ARE THERE FOR THE
STATE TO USE TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT WHAT IS BEING OUTLINED
IN S. B. TEN FOURTEEN AND THAT'S
WHAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
VOTE.
JULIE MOUNT ASK BOBBY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION
ACTUALLY TO BUILD ON WHAT MISTER
BLISS JUST SAID --
EDUCATION AND AWARENESS IS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST BARRIERS WE HAVE
TO REACH IN OURS HAVE GOALS AND
WHAT BETTER POSITION ARE TNC
DRIVERS AND TO BUILD THAT
EDUCATION AWARENESS WHEN A
DRIVER GETS IN A CAR.
THAT IS A ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
IT IS SEEN THAT IT'S PRACTICAL
IT COULD BE USED FOR THEIR
EVERYDAY PURPOSES AS WELL.
SO WE WOULD SAY ALL THE STATE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY INVESTED IN THE ONES
THAT WE JUST HEARD ABOUT THEY
ACTUALLY WILL BE MORE EFFECTIVE
WHEN EDUCATION AWARENESS IS
ACTUALLY A PART OF THE THE
PROGRAM.
THAT WE SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE AND SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION IMPOSITION ONLY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN
WHITE WITH THE CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
HI WILL BEAR WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE COALITION
pCATHERINE BRANDENBURG
REPRESENTING CINEMA CLEAN POWER
AND SUPPLY.
JASON VARGAS WITH A UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT.
ARIEL HAMEL ON BEHALF CAL START
ME ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
STILL THE ASSEMBLY SHAMI HAVE
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY
INSTRUCTS.
CATHERINE GARCIA WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
I CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO MEMBERS --
AWESOME HE WITH UBER --
WE'RE IN AN OPPOSE LET'S AMENDED
POSITION AND CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE --
WHILE WE SUPPORT THE EXPANDED
USE OF UAVS AND AGREE RIDE
SHARING HAS STRONG POTENTIAL
CONTRIBUTORS TOWARDS MORE SHARED
ELECTRIC MOBILITY.
WOULDLEAVE THE BILL IMPRINT ONE
UNNECESSARILY HARM RIGHT SHARING
AND WRITE YOUR DRIVER'S WHICH
ARE SIMPLY A SUBSET OF OVERALL
ROAD USERS WITHOUT MAKING
INTENDED PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
INTENDED.
VARMA OUTCOMES WE'VE MADE SOME
PROGRESS WORK WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE BILL NOW HAS A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK THAT BETTER CAPTURES
TNC IS CLIMATE IMPACT.
THROUGH WHICH TRANSITION ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES A CORE
COMPONENT.
HOWEVER WE HAVE SEEN IT
SIGNIFICANCE EARNS A REMAIN AS
BE TEN FOURTEEN SHOULD FOCUS
MORE ON INCENTIVIZING AND
CLEARING OBSTACLES FOR THE
DESIRED OUTCOME.
MORE SHARED ELECTRIC MILES AND
LOWER EMISSIONS THE WRITER
SECTOR.
THESE OBSTACLES INCLUDE THE FACT
THAT EVEN THE TNC TRAVIS TODAY
ARE OFTEN WERE SOFTER TO RANGE
LIMITATIONS.
DOWNTIME WAITING TO CHARGE THEIR
VEHICLES AND THE LACK OF PUBLIC
PASSED CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AMONG OTHERS.
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT MARKET
INFRASTRUCTURE CHANGES THAT MAKE
YOU THESE MORE ECONOMICALLY
VIABLE DRIVERS OF POTENTIALLY
EARN LESS THAN ANY OF THE
COLLECTIVELY IMPROVING THESE
ISSUES WILL NATURALLY DO MORE
EASE ONTO PAN LEFT.
ANY REASON BECOMING MORE
COMPETITIVE CHOICE.
THE CURRENT BILL TARGETS ONLY
TEENS EVE SEE VEHICLES WITHOUT
FAILING TO LEVERAGE ANY POLICIES
THAT WOULD CAPITALIZE ON THE
POTENTIAL RIDE SHARING OFFERS.
I CENTER SKINNER MENTIONED UBER
ANNOUNCED A NATIONWIDE PROGRAM
INVOLVING FOUR MAJOR CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN WHICH UBER EVEY
DRIVERS.
WILL RECEIVE INCENTIVES FOR
TRIPS COMPLETED ANY OF THESE
ADDITIONALLY MILLIONS OF WRITERS
WILL BE PROVIDED EDUCATION
MATERIAL IN ONLINE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OFFERED BY
YOU HE'S DEVELOP BY LEADING
EXPERTS.
WE'RE LEVERAGING A PLATFORM TO
DO THE BIGGEST TV WRITING DRIVE
OVER THE NEXT YEAR WITH THE GOAL
OF COMPLETING FIVE MILLION TV
TRIPS.
WE'RE DOING THIS TO LEARN WHAT
WORKS AND BOOST EDUCATION
AWARENESS AS MENTIONED BY THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS --
RIGHT TRAIN HAS AN ABSOLUTE ROLE
TO PLAY HERE AT ALONG THE LINES
OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S GOAL OF
GETTING TO FIVE MILLIONS AS BY
TWENTY THIRTY IN THE RAMP UP
TOWARDS THAT.
CAN HAVE A LOT GREATER IMPACT AN
OFFSET MORE MISSIONS IF WE
INVITE AND INVOLVE MORE PEOPLE
AT THOSE ADS ARE USING TO SHARE
CAPACITY --
BASIC IMPORTANT KEEP IN MIND THE
TNC TODAY ACCORDING TO PIECE
YEAR PORT CANNOT THE CAME ON
APRIL ARE STILL LISTEN 2% OF
YOUNG TEEN CALIFORNIA AND LESS
THAN 1% LESS THAN HALF A PERCENT
OF OVERALL EMISSIONS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR --
SO IN ADDITION TO THE AMENDMENT
REFERENCE IN THE HOUSES WERE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR HOPING
TO SEE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
ENSURE THAT THESE GOALS.
DEVELOP BY CARBON THE P. YOU SEE
ARE TIED RELATED MARKING
CONDITIONS ARE ECONOMICALLY
VIABLE.
AND DIRECT ONGOING STATE
PLANNING EFFORTS AND FUNDING
PROGRAMS ALIGNED WITH THE GOALS
OF THIS BILL.
ENCOURAGE PARTNERSHIPS ROUTINES
USING UTILITIES AND CHARGING AND
CHARGING PROVIDERS THAT WILL
HELP LINE.
BUT NOT AS WELL WITH WITH THE
GOALS OF THIS BILL.
AND LASTLY ENSURE THESE
PROVISIONS ALSO PLAYED A CURRENT
FUTURE RIGHT ENTRANCE AND THE
WRITER SPACE AS THE MARK AS THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF IS RAPIDLY
CHANGING.
SO LOOK FORWARD WITH THE AUTHOR
IN THE COMMITTEE IMPROVE THIS
PROPOSAL AND SET A PATH A RIGHT
TURN TO CONTRIBUTE TOWARDS
CALIFORNIA ELECTION FAKE
ELECTRIFICATION GOALS THANK YOU.
THE SHERMAN MEMBERS DON'T
INFECTIOUS REPRESENTING LEFT--
ECHO AUSTIN'S --
COMMENTS ONE I THINK THE SENATOR
FOR HER WORK ON THIS BILL WE
SHARE MANY OF THE GOALS --
IT IT EMBODIED IN THE BILL.
WE STILL BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A
WAY TO GO PRINCIPALLY AROUND THE
LANDING.
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THAT MANY OF
THE FOLKS TALK ABOUT TODAY --
VARIOUS POTS OF MONEY TO LINE
THEM WITH.
T. IN SEASON HOW WE ULTIMATELY
GET THERE WE WANT TO BE WE WANNA
PLAY A CONSTRUCTIVE ROLE IN THIS
WHERE WE CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
I'M WE WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
A WHAT WERE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
I LIKE TO OPEN THE OPEN THE ROLE
ON EIGHT TWO TWO S. B..
EIGHT TO TWO HOLD FOR A SECOND.
S. B. EIGHT TO TO DUE PROCESS
AMENDED TO PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I RODRIGUEZ. SEVEN
TWO MEASURES UP.
JERRY SANTIAGO AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS UNTIL KELLY ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL DIVERSITY COALITION
THE NATION NOT WIDE NETWORK OF
STATE AND LOCAL EFFORTS TO
ADVANCE DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
WERE TESTIFYING TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN FOURTEEN
WELL WE APPRECIATE EFFORTS TO
SPUR ELECTRIC VEHICLE ADOPTION
IN THE STATE S. B. TEN FOURTEEN
DOES LITTLE IN THE WAY OF
HELPING HARDWORKING CALIFORNIANS
MAKE ENDS MEET.
INSTEAD IT PLEASES UNREALISTIC
DEMANDS ON DRIVERS ESPECIALLY
THOSE OF MODEST MEANS AND
THREATENS TO UP AND THE FLEXIBLE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WRITERS HAVE PROVIDED. 50% OF
DRIVERS ON THE LEFT PLATFORM OUR
LOW INCOME 93% DRIVE FEWER THAN
TWENTY HOURS PER WEEK THERE ALSO
TECHNOLOGICAL AND PRACTICAL
CHALLENGES TO THE AIMS OF S. B..
TEN FOURTEEN POOR VEHICLE RANGE
LACK OF TV CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ALL MAKE IT HE'S
IMPRACTICAL FOR RIDE SHARE
DRIVERS WHO CANNOT PREDICT WHERE
THEIR NEXT RIDES WILL TAKE THEM --
OVER OR UNDER IT UNABLE OR
UNWILLING TO SPEND THE
ADDITIONAL TIME REQUIRED TO
RECHARGE DURING THEIR DRIVE
RIGHT CHIANG TIME --
AS WE TEN FOURTEEN UNFAIRLY
PENALIZES HARDWORKING TNC
DRIVERS POTENTIALLY PUSHING THE
VAST MAJORITY WHO DO NOT HAVING
CANNOT AFFORD AN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE OFF THE PLATFORM.
AND HITTING LOW INCOME MINORITY
GROUPS THE HARDEST WE HUMBLY ASK
YOUR NO VOTE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ONCE AGAIN NAME
AFFILIATION POSITIONALLY.
HI MY NAME IS ALICIA GONZALEZ ON
THE PROWL DRIVE FOR LIFT AND I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
LET'S SEPARATE REPRESENTING THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN OPPOSITION.
LARA BUT IT WITH TECHNICALLY THE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED PETITION.
WE S. OR THORN CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE OPPOSING
LESS AMENDED.
KEVIN MCKINLEY WITH INTERNET
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED [inaudible]
BOB.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SO LOOK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR --
SENATOR SKINNER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF AN A FIRST US ALL THIS
BILL I WAS ACTUALLY QUITE
DELIGHTED --
WITH THE THE CONCEPTUAL NATURE
OF WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT
IS SO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT AND AS YOU KNOW OFTENTIMES
WITH LEGISLATIVE INTENT IT'S THE
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES.
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
TESTIMONY THERE ARE SOME UNIQUE
DISTINCTIONS WITH RESPECT TO
OTHER FOR HIGHER TRANSPORTATION
ALSO TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES THAT YOU'RE WELL AWARE
OF TWO AND ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
THE POLICIES IN PLACE FOR THAT
SIMILAR TYPE OF INCENTIVES --
CAN YOU GIVE A SENSE ON THE FROM
AS THE AUTHOR THE LET'S ENDING
THAT.
DISCREPANCY IN THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THAT OF TNC EASE AND
ENSURING THAT WE WANT.
TO GET TO A CERTAIN GOAL OF
ENVIRONMENTAL TARGETS BUT ALSO
ENSURING THAT THE INCENTIVES ARE
IN PLACE FOR SIMILAR OTHER FOR
HIGHER TRANSPORT.
SO A COUPLE SPECIFICS ONE THE
BILL IS NOT THE IS WRITTEN
[inaudible]
TO ON MILES SO IT WOULD NOT.
NECESSARILY AFFECT ALL DRIVERS
ON THE PLATFORM OR ALL VEHICLES
ON THE PLATFORM THE REAL.
POINT IN A FOR THINKING OF IT
FROM THE POINT OF VIEW WAS
CERTAINLY THE THE STATE HAS.
A VERY AMBITIOUS FIVE MILLION
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE CALL AND
IF WE ARE JUST TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT THERE WOULD ONE AFFECT ALL
VEHICLES AND ALL DRIVERS ON THE
PLATFORM.
BUT BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO
BALANCE THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
SOME DRIVERS THAT YOU KNOW
REALLY ONLY USE ONLY DRIVE --
FOR TNC VERY FEW HOURS A WEEK
AND PROBABLY VERY FEW MILES AND
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT WHY DO WE
HAVE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE GOAL
BECAUSE WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS SO WHERE WE
GETTING THE MOST TAILPIPE
EMISSIONS.
FROM THE VEHICLES THAT ARE
DRIVING THE MOST MILES SO THAT'S
WHY I'VE DESIGNED THE BILL TO BE
TARGETED TOWARDS MILES SO WOULD
POTENTIALLY IMPACT ONLY THOSE
DRIVERS WHO ARE REALLY.
USING THEIR VEHICLE IT FROM MANY
MORE HOURS AND MANY MORE MILES
ON A TNC PLATFORM NOW
ADDITIONALLY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE ONLY RECENT --
ADVANCES IN TERMS OF SOME MODELS
WITH GREAT RANGE AND IT'S A
LEGITIMATE ISSUE THAT IF YOU'RE
IN ONE OF THE OLD VERSION NEED
THESE THAT HAS VERY LIMITED
RANGE IT REALLY DOES PUT YOU AT
A DISADVANTAGE.
BUT THE BILL HAS THESE MILES
TARGETS AS VERY GRADUAL AND IS
NOW DESIGNED TO ALLOW BOTH THEY
ARE BEING P. YOU SEE DE
DETERMINED.
WHAT IF TO FACTOR IN THINGS LIKE
THE AVAILABILITY OF VEHICLES
WITH A WIDE RANGE SO IN OTHER
WORDS IF THE MARKET CONDITIONS
ARE SUCH?
THAT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET
THE GOALS THEN THEY WILL BE
DELAYED OR THEY WILL BE MODIFIED
SO I'VE STRIPPED WHAT THE
SPECIFIC GOALS ARE TO ALLOW. TO
FACTOR IN THOSE MARKET
CONDITIONS ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
AND YOU DIDN'T ASK THIS QUESTION
IF YOU TURN TO NINE PAGE NINE OF
THE BILL.
IT SPECIFIES THAT THE DAY WILL
NEED TO ENSURE A MINIMAL
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON LOW INCOME
AND MODERATE INCOME DRIVERS SO
AGAIN.
THAT THIS NOTION THAT THIS BILL
WOULD UNFAIRLY HARM THE LOW
INCOME DRIVERS IT IS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO FACTOR
THAT.
AND AS I INDICATED BEFORE OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS WHERE THE
STATE HAS INVESTED TO HELP MEET
OUR GOALS.
TARGET SPECIFICALLY.
LOW INCOME DRIVERS TO HAVE THEM
BENEFIT MOST SO.
I THINK HOPEFULLY THOSE HER
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
YOU RACED.
YES SIR OF A MY MISTER TO A PART
OF THE CHALLENGE I THINK AGAIN
THAT THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN OF
FOR HIRE TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
AND TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES.
OTHER NUANCES BETWEEN THEM AND
UNDERSTANDING THE POLICIES DON'T
NECESSARILY FIT IN --
AND WITH LEGISLATIVE INTENT THAT
YOU HAVE I DO THINK THAT'S
MERITS FURTHER CONVERSATION TO
MOVE FORWARD AND I WILL SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE I DO.
APPRECIATE THE INTENT BUT I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL.
SAYS TO IDENTIFY THE
DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN THAT OF THE
INCENTIVES IN TRYING TO MAKE IT
ALSO WORK OF IT BECAUSE WE WANT
TO SEE THESE TREACHEROUS NETWORK
COMPANIES ALSO COMPLY AND ALSO
JOIN US IN OUR IN OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS --
SO I I AM I AM HOPEFUL THAT
YOU'LL STAY COMMITTED --
IN THE GOOD FAITH TO THAT AS
WELL SO WITH THAT I WILL MOVE
THE BILL.
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR UP.
SENATOR OF SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL --
I'M WONDERING FIRST DO WE PUT A
SIMILAR REQUIREMENT ON THE
COMPANIES THAT THESE TNC EASE
COMPETE WITH LIKE TAXI COMPANIES
OF LOS.
I'M WE THERE ARE REQUIREMENTS
NOW AND FLEET OWNERS.
I IN FACT I CARRIED A BILL FOR
WITH THAT WHERE THE A ARE BEING
NOW BOTH THE STATE FLEET MUST
MEET A CERTAIN PERCENT OF THESE
ZAPS.
AND ARB IS NOW IN POWER TO
IMPOSE THAT ON PRIVATE SECTOR
FLEETS THEY'VE NOT DONE THE
REGULATORY ACTIONS YET BUT THEY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO SO.
AND TAXIS IN MANY CASES ARE
CONSIDERED A FLEET SO WE HAVE
THAT FOR FLEETS AT THE MOMENT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS.
THAT HAVE IMPOSED EVEN STRONGER
GOALS THE NO WHAT'S IN THIS BILL
ON THEIR TAXI FLEETS BUT AS WE
KNOW FOR ITS JUST FOCUS ON TAXIS
FOR THE MOMENT.
THEY ARE A SHRINKING PORTION OF
OF SO FOR RELIEF TRYING TO DEAL
WITH -- WHAT
ARE THE LARGEST GROWTH OF VMT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES OTHER THAN JUST
YOU AND I INDIVIDUALLY DRIVING --
THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY PRIVATE
SECTOR FLEETS AND AND IN SOME
CASES TNC SO THERE IS NOW IN
STATUTE THE ABILITY.
FOR A ARE BE TO IMPOSE AT
SIMILAR THINGS AND WILL BUT WE
HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE WHAT TYPE
OF RULE MAKING THE DO
[inaudible]
OKAY THE IT'S I HAVE A CONCERN
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I DON'T FEEL
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE NEVER PUT ITS FINGER
ON THE SCALE OF OF ONE AND NOT
OTHERS WHICH IS WHY I READ THE
BILL'S REGARDING FLEETS LAST
YEAR AND A PASSED AND SIGNED
INTO LAW.
SURE WYOMING OUT THAT'S ONE OF
THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE IS THAT
IF IT WERE.
A AFFECTING THE ABILITY OF THESE
COMPANIES TO COMPETE WITH EACH
OTHER AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S A SOMETHING THAT WE OUGHT
TO BE DOING --
I ALSO HAVE A CONCERN BECAUSE
AND TO ME THAT THE TNC IS HAVE A
SUFFICIENT LEVEL OF ABILITY TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE VEHICLES DON'T
BELONG TO THEM THEY'RE NOT
REALLY FLEET OPERATORS THERE.
THOSE VEHICLES BELONG TO THE
DRIVER'S WEAPON TO APPLY TO BE --
DRIVERS FOR THE TNC AND I'LL
GIVE AN EXAMPLE FROM MY OWN
HOMETOWN --
I THINK WE HAVE.
ONE TNC DRIVER.
AND IF YOU WANT TO GET A LIFT OR
A COOPER YOU ARE JUST AT THE
MERCY OF WHETHER NOT HE'S GOT
HIS APPLICATION OPEN RIGHT.
AND I I REPRESENT ARE I MEAN I
THE SECOND LARGEST DISTRICT IN
THE STATE I I I HAVE A LOT OF
RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
EXACTLY THAT SAME SITUATION AND
MY FEAR IS THAT BY.
IMPOSING THIS REQUIREMENT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT.
THE ABILITY OF THOSE DRIVERS
STEPHEN DRIVE FOR THE TNC CAN
TNC MIGHT HAVE TO TELL THOSE
DRIVERS OF THEY DON'T HAPPEN TO
OWN A ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE THEY
MIGHT HAVE TO TELL THOSE DRIVERS
I'M SORRY.
WERE ALREADY AT OUR LIMIT AND
YEAH YOU CAN'T DRIVE FOR US SO
BUT THAT'S WHILE AFTER
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
ANY FOR THE QUESTION FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE --
THANK YOU I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY HAD A GOOD LINK THE
HEARING WE HAD A GOOD DISCUSSION
ON THE BILL OR RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT VOTE.
WITH THE AMENDED.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL ROLL.
YOU MOST SECOND.
I AM SUBJECT PLEASE CALL ROLL.
BUSH'S DO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION.
SANTIAGO HIGH SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW AYE LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
QUIKSILVER NO [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
THE MEASURE LONG CALL.
THEY MET CENTER [inaudible]
SENATE ROTH.
I WILL BE PRESENTING SP.
TEN EIGHT WITH THE BILL
[inaudible]
SECOND.
MAYBE I SHOULD THE COULD WELL
I'M WINNING MET MISTER CHAIR TH.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY --
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES A SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES SUPPORT I
APOLOGIZE.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IS A
POOR PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND AND YOUR
POSITION [inaudible]
BUT REALLY DAVIS SENIOR PUBLIC
POLICY MANAGER WITH LEFT
[inaudible]
I'M.
WHICH IS VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT I
SP TEN ET AT REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY TO
DRIVE FOR KINSEY'S.
WHILE OPERATING AND WHILE BEING
AYE STATIONED IN CALIFORNIA NOT
ONLY THAT IT ALSO OPENS UP THIS
SITE EARNING OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
DEPENDENTS SO THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO NOT ONLY PROVIDE FOR ATHLETES
LOW INCOME BUT ALSO TO PROVIDE
RIGHTS FOR THE BASE AND ALSO THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES.
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE I STARTED
SPEAKING BEFORE I SAW YOU
WALKING UP SO.
SO NOW WILL CONTINUE WITH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES OF SUPPORT
PLEASE JUST AYE YOUR NAME
POSITION.
LIKE GREG HAYES HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT.
KEVIN MCKINLEY ON BEHALF
INTERNET ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THE ESERVER THORN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
LARA BENNETT WITH TECHNICIAN
SUPPORT.
CRITICS BRADLEY LIVE DRIVER
FORMER MILITARY OFFICER US
AIRFORCE AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
ANY WITNESSES.
TYPICALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA AND THE AMERICAN LEGION
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
ANYWAY --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND QUESTION FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
MA'AM SPECTRA PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WASHES DO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION SANTIAGO AYE AYE
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF LOW.
LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS PATTERSON FOLKS OVER.
POSTED VIA I'VE READ REDUCE
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
SP.
TEN EIGHTY ORIGINALLY NEWMAN
BILL [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN I ZERO MEASURES N
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL.
OR LEAVE THE RULED ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WE ARE.
BE LET'S BEGIN LEADING UP FOLKS
AT ON
BUT THE CALL.
WHAT WE DO YEAH?
OKAY LITTLE IF THE CALL ON S. B. --
TEN OF FOURTEEN SKINNER.
MADAM O'CLOCK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
S. B. TEMPLETON MOTION AS DO
PASTA COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA AYE [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.%
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO.
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RIGHT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
CALL MEASURES BACK ON CALL.
LET'S LET THE CALL AN SP.
TEN EIGHTY ON ROTH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BUSH'S DO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
MATHIS PATTERSON [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
THE MEASURES BACK ON PAUL
COLLEGE LOOKED FOR CALL ON SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX HILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible] TWO ZERO
MOTIONS DO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION.
S. B..
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX OBERNOLTE
NO OBERNOLTE NO BONTA.
BONTA AYE CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NOT VOTING.
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
QUICKSILVER.
KIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
THE MEASURES BACK ON CALL.
LOOK THE CALL ON FILE ITEM SIX
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR HELL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CURRENT MOTION IS DO PASTA
PUBLIC SAFETY.
OBERNOLTE NO OBERNOLTE NO.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS PATTERSON
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
BUT MEASURES BACK ON CALL
.
THE SERGEANTS RECALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS
.
S. B.. TEN FOURTEEN ITEM NUMBER
THREE MOTION IS DO PASTA
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
BROADWAY DESAI.
THE MEASURES BACK ON COLLEGE
REOPEN THE ROLE FOR FILE ITEM
FOR S. B. TEN EIGHTY ARE ROTH
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PAUSE TO COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I THE MEASURES BACK ON
CALL.
RITA REOPEN THE ROLE FOR FILE
ITEM FIVE SP THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SIX HO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
BUSH'S DO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I I MEASURES BACK ON
CALL.
AND WILL REOPEN THE ROLE FOR
FILE ITEM SIX S. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR HILL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASTA PUBLIC SAFETY
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I THE MEASURE IS BACK
ON CALL.
YOU WERE ON A
DAVID
[inaudible]
BUT OPENING UP US FOR AT ARMS
WILL START A FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO S. B..
EIGHT TWO TWO MOTIONS DEPOSITS
AS AMENDED TO COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
FOR ADULTS MISTER BONTA.
BONTA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I A TO TO MEASURES UP.
WITHIN THE CON S. B.
[inaudible]
TEN TO FOURTEEN CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
MEASURE BACK ON CALL.
S. B. [inaudible]
TEN EIGHTY CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I EDUARDO GARCIA
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I COME LIKE A DOVE
[inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON. NINE ZERO MEASURES
OUT.
S. B. [inaudible]
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO GARCIA
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE OF MATHIS
[inaudible]
PATTERSON.
SOMEONE MEASURES OUT.
S. B. [inaudible]
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE.
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE OF MATHIS
PATTERSON. EIGHT TWO ONE
MEASURES OUT
.
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN AND
WAIT FOR UPS IN NUMBERS
.
LIPPMAN CALLED ITEM NUMBER THREE
SB. TEN FOURTEEN S. B. TEN
FOURTEEN MOTION IS TO PASTA
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON. SEVEN THREE MEASURES
UP
.
I STILL BELIEVE THE ROLE OF THE
PROPS MEMBERS
.
I DON'T.
THINK
SENATE BILL IN OWN HAS
PULLED THE BILL